[Music]
[Applause]
he
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
n
[Music]
he
[Applause]
[Music]
he
the premier online speed chess
tournament a knockout filled with
tension drama quick tactics and shocking
moments oh my
gosh for the last seven years in
counting the best Blitz and bullet
players in the world have flocked to
chess.com to prove their worth at this
format excitement Reigns every year with
major upsets and intense
battles this year 12 invitees and four
qualifiers face off for the title dozens
have tried but only two have ever worn
this Crown Magnus makes it look easy
over he wins the speed chest
Championship it's fifth in a row who
will be this year's Blitz King it's time
to find
out welcome to the 2023 speed Chess
Championship presented by
[Music]
coinbase welcome back to the 2023 speed
Chess Championship presented by coinbase
we are excited to welcome coinbase as
the presenting partner of the speed
Chess Championship I'm Grand Master
Robert H has alongside me once again is
Grandmaster Benjamin Buck Benjamin we
had an exciting day of Chess yesterday
we did see y pomi take down our generic
gy today Yan has none other than world
number one Magnus Carlson as his
opponent hey grow great to be here with
you today it's an exciting day it's it's
an exciting dat because we have Magnus
Carlson taking on taking on Yan Pachi
and Robert is is a rematch of the 2021
World Chess
Championship it is indeed a rematch of
that world championship in
2021 and Magnus Carlson he took that
title in fewer games than were required
of the match so Magnus you see the final
moves of that Championship they finally
they shake hands Magnus retains the
title but Benjamin I think Yan wants a
different outcome today yeah and I'm for
sure today is going to be different that
was a classical World Chess Championship
match today is going to be fast and
furious as they take each other on in
the speed Chess
Championship yes so for yand pomi it's a
different version of himself having won
two candidates tournaments you know his
name is up there with the best in the
world but unfortunately for him he plays
the absolute best in the world the
number one player for over a decade in
Magnus Carlson so let's dive in to the
bracket to see how the players were able
to make their way to the quarterfinals
and Benjamin we already know two of our
semi-finalists car Nakamura beat F
Carana yesterday and Wesley so took down
fuja a couple days ago so Magnus Carlson
yand pomi the winner of this upcoming
match will face Wesley in the
semis yeah know this is going to be a
very exciting matchup so yeah the winner
will face Wesley and that would pave the
way to a potential final again and he we
seen that upper bracket Hikaru he's
marching onto the final as well hiar
Nakamura Magnus Carlson maintains of
Mainstays I should say of the speed
chest championship and for Magnus it was
business as usual in The Opening match
against vidit GUI because Magnus he
ended up with a ninepoint victory over
the Indian Super grandm so Benjamin I
think that Magnus though he was hard on
himself in the postmatch interview he
took care of it when he needed to yeah
it was just a regular day at the office
it seemed for Magnus vidit gave him a
very good match but overall Magnus won
quite convincingly and we see that
especially the biggest difference was in
the bullet portion and yeah we we saw we
saw Jan's match y will have to really
play at his aame to give him Magnus a
tough match here and Magnus Carlson
92% 7% average accuracy in the opening
round six brilliancies compared to none
for his opponent he had the highest
average accuracy in the first round so
Magnus doing Magnus things and on the
other side of this match will be y the
PMI Benjamin his match against arent
that was very different that was a
nailbiter yeah that was very very up and
down Jan was leading for the most part
at some point he was even down in the
match but he won finally by a onepoint
difference Robert we see that he took
the lead in the five plus one origin at
some point was leading by two points but
Jan's neres were the strongest in the
final couple of games he took 3 and 1
half out of the Final Four Points to
steal Victory from the jaws of defeat
yand pomi moved on but if we look at
this graphic here the average accuracy
lower than magnus's and also nine
blunders Benjamin I don't think young
can afford that many against Magnus
Carlson no for sure not against arjin he
lost one game by disconnect also he lost
many he lost a few games right out of
the opening and against Magnus he has to
take every single opportunity that will
be presented him and he's got to try to
avoid losing games unnecessarily and the
good thing though for Yan is that if he
can get rid of those blooder there is a
lot of room for
improvement that's true because if he
doesn't lose in say 13 moves as he did
against Argent Yesterday by slipping in
the opening his chances will be better
and Jan was in a good mood at least a
jovial mood after the match because he
took to Twitter or should we call it X
these days he tweeted just a yawn so how
appropriate for his name but he was
trying to take that Michael Jordan route
he took it personally that he was not
initially invited to the
SEC yep but today he might be playing
the Michael Jordan off chess we know how
good Magnus Carlson is it was an
absolute Thriller that he beat arj Ari
yesterday but he's going to play much
better today if he wants to have a real
chance of beating
Magnus it's true because Magnus as we
keep talking about he is the final boss
often in the Chess World hiar Nakamura
he is a claim to that in the SEC as well
well but let's look at the tale of the
tape because it's important to dive into
the numbers and we are thrilled to have
deoe a leader in their field as the
official Data Insights partner for the
speed Chess Championship their
dedication to Excellence aligns
perfectly with the chess.com mission to
grow the game and sport of Chess let's
dive in to our deoe game analytics and
Benjamin here we see it Magnus much
higher rated in Blitz chess but they've
never actually played on chess.com how
crazy is that yeah it's quite remarkable
that they never played on chacom I think
it's because Yan wasn't active for a
while Magnus also was not active but
Robert look at the numbers their cheson
Blitz rating is almost is more than 200
points apart that is a very big very big
margin it really is and it cannot be
overstated because Magnus he's a blitz
beast and Yan pomi he's been improving
unfortunately Benjamin I sorry to bring
this up again we talked about his title
Tuesday win earlier in the week where
you fa him in the last round but it goes
to show that Yan maybe he's on the
upswing yeah know for sure he's been
working on his game he also used to be
up to 3200 so he he's he's definitely
capable of bringing his his aame he has
a high ceiling so to speak but he really
has to play at his aame today and he
also has to hope that Magnus will play a
little bit below his aame because in
magnus's aame he has a game win rate 56%
that's absolutely nuts he's the only
player above 50% that means each and
every game he plays he's 56% likely to
win it in the SEC so Yan needs to slow
that down and as you said Jan's ceiling
is very high but sometimes his floor is
a bit low as we saw him losing 13 moves
yesterday he needs to avoid those types
of
blunders yeah for sure he has to play
well from start to finish I wonder what
kind of preparation he has done going
into this match I also wonder how Magnus
will approach this we match we've seen
that hikaro has been playing bingo
pretty much playing 13 playing 1 H3
things of that nature I I wonder if
Magnus is going to take the opening a
little bit more
seriously and well Magnus Carlson we
know he's the heavy favorite let's jump
into the smarter chess predictions I
typically you know have some beef with
those predictions but I think this one
won't be too much of a surprise Magnus
Carlson predicted to win by a final
score of 18- 10 85% win probability
Benjamin does that meet your
expectations yeah now I think Magnus is
a pretty hefty favorite to win this one
we see that his biggest Edge will
probably be in the bullet portion y he
uh while he was behind in the bullet
portion but eventually he won the match
yesterday against Argent there but um
yeah we saw also that Magnus W by big
margin and bullet bullets very much come
down to your intuition and we know that
magnus's intuition maybe it's on par
with with hiar but other than that he's
he's often destroying people there yes
not many can match up with Magnus
Carlson who's a two-time winner of the
speed chest Championship chat get
involved let us know your predictions
will it be the man on the screen in
front of you Magnus Carlson winning this
match or do you think Yan NPI can get
revenge for the 2021 world championship
and Yan he's looking refreshed I mean
he's looking like a man who's ready to
take on the number one player in the
world but he needs to improve yesterday
was a win it was a close one but it's
not going to be good enough to take down
Magnus yeah know for sure yeah again he
has to play better than yesterday
yesterday he was a little bit sloppy at
times like we said you know making
losing some games right out of the open
opening you cannot afford that at all
also he let some opportuni slip so again
if he brings his aame I think we are in
for a very exciting match the question
is if he
can that's the question that only he can
answer and the games are going to start
in any second now we see Magnus is
adjusting his camera Yan he looks
focused Benjamin I'm excited for this
one yeah and I'm excited for sure it's
uh again the rematch of the 2021 World
chest Championship so this one might
also to be a little bit personal for
both of the players also again these
players are from the same generation
they're both born in 1990 as we speak by
the way we're off and again like they've
played in World youth under their 12
championships and they go way way back
and Y actually had the lead in their
head-to-head history until that world
championship match when it was a
one-sided victory for Magnus we have a
petro and for this match I'm wondering
is Yan going to try to be more solid or
is he going to bring his chaotic brand
of chess which has scored him some fine
victories in his career but also can
backfire if you play a little too Lucy
goosey yeah I think he's going to try to
stick to a style try to play
aggressively especially with the white
piece against Magnus he wasn't quite
able to do so in the match but that is
also very impressive from mang's part
that he doesn't let Yan into his aame so
to speak and he turned the game into
more grindy slow positions but let's see
what we have here Robert we had it
started out out as a Petro but it turned
into a bit of a French exchange pretty
boring so far but we know how Magnus can
work his magic here we see Magnus he's
eating his lunch so he's just taking it
step by step but I agree with you the
reason why we call this position a bit
boring so to speak is there's no Pawn
tension only one Pawn has been traded
per side we haven't seen anything of
note in a symmetrical structure so let's
see how this one develops but I wonder
Benjamin do you think it's match
strategy for Magnus not just to get his
meal in at the start but to sort of see
what Jan wants in the opening
stages yeah and I think it definitely
makes sense to see what what Yan wants
Jan has been singing to his guns he
played the petrol defense he played that
in their world championship match as
well I'm not too impressed so far with
magnus's opening choice I think Yan's
doing fairly well I mean Magnus has
these slightly more active pieces
however this n C3 can sometimes be
slightly misplaced as it's currently
restricted by the pawn of C6 Queen E2 I
like the move by Magnus as H6 would
invite a sacrifice over here but not
have f a nice move by Yan and look at
the clock Robert Yan does this very well
he's already up on the up on time and
perhaps Magnus might be struggling a
little bit with this uh because normally
he's the one putting pressure and Yan
often is the one putting pressure on him
and look at this position The Rook gets
to the open file black can develop that
light Square Bishop to maybe E6 but it
does feel a little bit like Black's
pieces are fighting for the same squares
like both the Knight and the bishop want
to go to E6 that's a good Square for
them both so whites so far the pieces
feel a little bit more fluid there's a
more natural set of squares for them but
ultimately yeah I'm not super impressed
with what Magnus has done and yet he
wins games just like this that seem
unwinable that seem like nothing he'll
probably Knight E5 here and then it
starts to seem like he's going to go for
a bit of
initiative yeah 95 seems like a nice
move putting the nine in the middle I
wonder if young can take on D4 but that
does look fairly risky and there we see
move 95 now perhaps after kn D4 maybe
Magnus can take an F6 you're going to
have to recapture the G pawn and at the
very least there's something like Queen
H6 you can also take on D7 and take an
H7 so I suppose staying on D4 is too
risky for y maybe he has to play
something more solid like Bishop to E7
because for them oh and wow there we go
but we were saying at the start of the
show you can't afford blunders or sort
of crazy chest if it's not objectively
strong against Magnus Carlson that
earned a question mark and I think it's
simple Bishop takes Knight on F6 as you
mentioned you have to take with the pawn
PA on F6 and then even just take on D7
Black's Pawn structure is going to be
worse I love what Magnus has been able
to achieve from what looked like a
nothing
opening yeah so let's see what Magnus
has to do I think Bishop takes F6 is
certainly the start if you take with the
queen you leave the bishop on D7 hanging
so perhaps you're going to have to
recapture with the pawn now you can take
on D7 take on H7 afterwards and then
take on D4 and perhaps that is the
position that Jan is going for and he
might feel like after somethingone like
Queen F five he's not doing too bad but
I do wonder if mag can take and go Queen
H6 cuz how exactly do you stop the
threat of
Checkmate maybe black would have to play
Move Like Bishop F or Knight F5 or
something like that but yeah you are
hanging on barely at that stage so I
think Magnus is he's working out what
we're talking about right here you need
to be precise you need to come up with
the correct move order because if you
get a little bit lazy say with like
Knight takes D7 now Queen takes D7 maybe
at some point black will have a
different move order that helps his
chances yeah for sure so yeah it looks
extremely risky mag is investing some
time but I'm sure he's going to go down
this line with Bishop takes of six Pawn
takes what oh he takes on B he takes on
H7 wow Robert I guess in case it takes
ah he wants take F7 and for the queen
and the bishop oh that's actually pretty
nice I wasn't even looking in that
direction and in that situation the
queen and Bishop are forked and the
Knight on D4 is still loose so maybe
black has to throw in like a knight F3
check at some point just to shatter Pawn
structure but this does look like a
situation where Magnus has the upper
hand mag excuse me Yan he didn't expect
that he reacted to night takes like oh
didn't see that one
coming yeah no that's um yeah a little
bit sloppy by Yan I think knightx D4 was
a little bit rushed so let's see what
he's going to do here Knight F3
certainly possibility if white has to
take and then perhaps Queen C7 Magus has
to be doing well there I mean maybe it
feels like he's more likely to take take
advantage of the open G fou young can of
course also move the queen right away
way but after Queen takes D4 white is an
extra pawn and their King is safer this
looks really bad for black and you could
take on F6 at some moment for white if
you want to shatter the king set even
more because I don't think black can
ever afford to take that Bishop with the
queen swooping in to H6 so Benjamin this
is looking very problematic for Jan and
it went from a completely even looking
position and then Magnus makes one for
jump with his Knight earlier in the game
and Yan did not react in the best way
yeah we've been talking about this for
the match Jon again like he if he wants
to give himself a good chance he has to
try to avoid losing games like this he
has to try to hang in there usually he
plays faster than Magnus so perhaps he
can get Magnus into time pressure but if
he blunders early on then you're just
going to gift a lot of points to Magnus
and that's going to make it very tough
and when have we ever heard of Magnus
relinquishing a lead the matches that
he's lost that I can think of including
last year's speed Chess Championship to
Hikaru the bullet chest championship
match against both ala and Hikaru it he
was losing out of the gates and then he
was trying to come back so for Magnus
winning game one would be huge and for
Yan if anyone can win a game on demand I
I do trust Jan he is so creative but
it's just not what you want in a match
against Magnus Carlson no for sure
because Magnus he can also be extremely
solid and almost impossible to beat If
he if he wants to and yeah like I said I
think you have the best chance against
Magnus if you win early on hang on to
that lead that might also make him a
little bit nervous maybe he's going to
Rush a little bit to try to come back
and finally we see Yan settling on the
Move Queen to C7 so now let's see what
Magnus is going to do I guess he should
take on D4 just take the knight in case
of Knight takes D6 perhaps then Yan can
throw in that move Knight F3 check and
force you to double your pawns Knight
of3 check I think was not really a
possibility before because white also
has this option to go B Tak of six
combined with Queen H6 so I think right
now Magnus is either going to take this
Knight or take the Knight on D4 it's a
good call and the problem for Magnus is
he can only take one piece at a time and
if you take the Knight on F6 black for
sure will not take back with the G Pawn
I think that Knight on D4 will slide
back to F5 and you're just trying to
keep your king as safe as possible so
maybe white will remain up a pawn but
it's pawns on separate sides of the
board black has an extra Pawn of the
defile white has two extra pawns on the
king side and that creates a dynamic
imbalance that should help in Black's
chances to hold if white is not able to
crash through against that black king
yeah we see Magnus falling quite far
behind on clock here he's dropping below
a minute I think he he's still in very
good shape here he's got a dominant
position but you got to be careful
especially against Jan who's so
extremely pressure who ex who is so
extremely tricky when you're in time
pressure goes 96 wait but Robert that
was the mistake we were talking about I
think now Jan is doing quite fine
actually I'm not sure why Magnus went
for this because look at these pawns on
the king side now you have the split F
pawns and a Loose H Pawn that's under
attack he goes in with his Queen but
suddenly look at the eval bar saying
black is actually the side for choice
Knight E4 forcing those Queens off and
how could black be worse in this end
game double exclam deserved from Yan
because that way his King is safe
Benjamin this is starting to turn
around yeah great move by Yan he's
offering the trade of Queens I don't
think there's a good way for Magnus to
uh to get out of it and he does go for
the queen TR the pawn on H3 is hanging
now these pawns are weak Bishop F5 is an
option or Knight C4 attaining this OPP
and also Robert after Knight C4 you turn
to go Knight D2 and look at the clock
Magnus down to 18 seconds
and that's a very good response of King
to G2 because the Knight could take B2
but the Rook would have slid to B1 to
win the B7 pawn and get some activity so
very good find from Magnus I'm looking
at the clock he's down to 10 seconds
Benjamin he's got to move yeah Bishop
five great move by y not taking the PA
KN at E2 all right so Yan can just take
this Pawn over here now and get a pretty
significant Advantage I guess Magnus is
playing to go Knight D4 I I don't know
he's in real trouble here Robert perhaps
Yan can start of hot in this match it
didn't look like that at first but if he
grabs these queenside pawns I would take
on C2 as you said now black has this
unopposed D- Pawn passer White's pawns
they're gross double F and isolated H
they can't create a pass Pawn very
easily this looks like Yan neomi's game
he needs a pressure Magnus on the clock
yeah and that's what he's doing he takes
on D he takes on C2 goes Bishop D3 and
now he can take another Pawn he doesn't
do so now Magnus goes B3 the position
might be manageable here because where
do you actually go with a knight this
was a mistake from Yan should have
Pawn inste he's backtracking but look at
Magnus pushing forward A5 Follow by A6
was a threat and that's why black played
A5 but that's a long-term weakness if
that Bishop slides to C7 at the right
moment A5 could be a Target but look at
the clock Magnus down of 4 Seconds J has
to be doing well here but let's see if
he can create some problems for Magnus I
I think Magnus objectively he should be
doing fine like it's opposite color
Bishops these pawns are blocked over
here on the queen side it's difficult to
make use of them but the clock
the he's barely getting his moves off I
mean he's 2.9 seconds after that move
you gained 1 second of increment
everybody I think Bishop F4 was a good
choice that Bishop can go to E3 or to G5
it will block the black Rooks and now
Magnus might play B4 himself and just
start trading off
pawns yeah so let's see how Yana is
going to try to do this Rook G6 check I
guess we be met with Bishop to G5 he
goes Rook to C8 perhaps aiming to set
his Pawns in motion but for now you can
as well hang the PA on D5 and with the
move Bishop to G5 Magnus is actually
creating that threat oh
Pawn yes because it wasn't available a
move ago cuz Rook G6 would have been
check there's no check against the white
King The Rook on C8 is loose now Magnus
he can go from a position where he was
worse to potentially one where he could
try to outplay Yan although with Bishops
of opposite color this realistically
should just be a simp but H5 H5 was a
great move there H5 again and set
because you cannot take okay now yeah
he's he's setting up H5 now H5 is a big
threat right so King E8 therefore by Yan
okay so now we have H5 a couple moves to
like y just takes it okay King G3 this
game probably a job but it can still go
either way with both players getting
long time and here comes the F Pawn I
said they weren't good but pent f g G4
takes
G5 wow what a blunder and Rook takes F5
is just a game because you can wow and
Yan Pachi takes the first game
Robert it looked like Magnus was well on
his way to a first game victory at least
right after that Knight E5 and the
tactics happen but Yan pomi he's showing
that he can be resilient he can fight
back I cannot believe he won that game I
mean that it looked like there was no
chance and there was a one move blunder
because of time trouble and Yan he
capitalizes that was absolutely
incredible yeah Yan was doing well
before when he took the pawn on C2 he
could have also taking the pawn on B2
but after that Magnus seemed to be out
of the woods he had that opportunity to
go H5 on a couple of occasions he missed
it and then it seemed to he just had it
for a draw but then he made a terrible
blund with a five Robert oh my goodness
what a howler and I want to get the chat
involved once again do you change your
mind a lot of you had Magnus winning do
you still think that's going to be it
just one game I know but yand pomi he's
showing some good form in the first game
and here in the second it looks like
he's breaking open the queen side
Benjamin it looks like a Roy Lopez but
it started as a
sicilian exactly yeah it started off as
a Rosal limo and black played this line
with E5 and Bishop to D6 very creative I
think hikaru's also played this a couple
of times at some point white is going to
go D4 or or D3 and we will see a trade
here black will have this backwards Pawn
on D7 or or on D6 reminiscent of a sikov
but in return black has got a lot of uh
piece activity yeah look like a Spanish
a FES nikov that backwards Deon as
you're pointing out it could be a
problem but look at this Pawn on B5 it's
either a bad Pawn because white can
Target it and look at Yan not sure how
to take on D3 takes with the queen and
that Bishop on D6 is under threat so I
think it gives white just another
another move to develop because you have
to take care of the bishop Bishop G5
next potentially for white a rook to D1
and I have to say I do like the look of
this position for yand
pishi yeah it's a typical yand pishi
position he's got a slight initiative
easy pce play and Magnus has a couple of
weaknesses so I think Jon cannot be
unhappy at all about what he's got here
out of the opening but Robert we talked
about the match beforehand this is
exactly what Yan needs he needs a good
start and uh yeah this could potentially
become quite an exciting match for sure
this move B4 doesn't threaten anything I
think that Yan can just develop Knight
to D2 then bring that Knight to C4 and
just increase the potential of your
pieces that Rook on A1 is maybe the best
piece on the board because at some point
black would love to play Bishop A6
that's not going to happen and that
backwards D Pawn remains an
issue yeah for sure yon Cano always
going Knight C4 and Cas of D6 putting
pressure on that pawn like you said move
a rook to D1 and he's just got the
easier piece play he's got this open AA
for his rook in case Magnus moves his
Bishop let's say to E6 there's always
going to be an annoying Rook A6 move so
that is why we see that Magus is POS the
thing again I think yon he's he's doing
pretty well here so far and let's be
honest Benjamin did you expect at all
that yon would take a game like that in
the first one where it seemed like a
very typical Magnus type of position
better could you have expected Jan to
take that first game and then now have a
slightly better position in the game two
I did not expect it I did not expect it
but Magnus has to be a little bit
careful he's going down on the clock
again we saw in game one he had a
dominant position but with only seconds
on the clock really anything can happen
a one second increment really is not a
whole lot and everyone makes a big
mistakes and it's part of Yan's overall
match strategy we saw that yesterday he
likes to be faster than his opponent and
speaking of faster this Knight goes to
C4 and look at how quickly it will land
on E3 and F5 and D5 and watch out
because if you get Knight D5 that Knight
F6 is pinned and if you do take what say
a bishop on D5 after e takes D5 they are
checkmating ideas across the
diagonal exactly yeah y would L to open
up this thing G5 wow is he going to go
for Knight G5 sack it yeah look at the
time look at Black's King Benjamin come
on would you be able to
resist I mean perhaps but I don't think
yon will be able to I think he's going
to go for it so let's see so Tak takes
Queen E6 what exactly is the follow-up
Robert I haven't figured that out but F4
is typically a good move to play when
your opponent's king is open and you're
trying to open not just the f file but
also the diagonal from B1 to H7 for
checkmating ideas it looks scary and Yan
probably wants to make sure he at least
has a bailout for everyone who's
watching that's important maybe he sees
a variation where he can at least Force
the draw he probably didn't so he goes
Bishop to G3 and as you see the x marks
the spot but it also marks the Miss
Knight takes G5 was
better yeah Bish G3 he still keeps an
initiative he has pressure on the E5
Pawn also in case Magnus goes D6 he has
pressure there so perhaps he feels like
he has an advantage here as well and so
it wasn't necessary to go for it but
Robert that would that might have been a
missed opportunity I like what you
suggested there with thing on G5
followed by
F4 it looks like it just blast open the
black king side but perhaps Yan he you
know he trusts himself of course he's a
very intuitive player but he knows that
at sometimes he has gone a little bit
too far and so I think your point is
well taken Benjamin his position is
still good in fact the eval bar is the
same now as if Knight takes G5 so why
did he have to sacrifice material he
says let me just play this very goodl
looking position and we keep talking
about this Yan you know who beats Jan
the most is himself so he does not want
to do that in this match yeah Knight E3
here in the meantime nice move by Yan
Knight d8 by Magnus all right so let's
see what Jan's going to do here I mean
he can move Rook to D1 Rook A7 is a
possibility Knight d8 looks a little bit
a to me as I don't see where the Knight
is headed they cannot go to E6 as you
allow the Knight to jump to F5 we see
just Rook F1 by by Yan and again this is
where he's good at he's got a lead on
the clock he's got that initiative and
Magnus is struggling so far and I'm
trying to figure out why oh my goodness
there are some tactics I think with like
a knight D4 and a knight D5 if black is
not careful that's what rookie one might
have set up here because there's going
to be a Checkmate on the H7 Square this
is getting very difficult for madus and
he plays Bishop B6 so I'm wondering is
ah the bishop just defended on B6 now
that might be a huge
difference no can still wait Knight D4
yeah in case you take there might be
moose like Knight D5 combined with a
timely E5 push and white always has that
check MTI here on H7 so I think after
Knight D4 black might have take with the
bishop to stop by from putting a knight
on F5 but that looks terrible so he goes
Rook to B1 how can you blame him from
changing his Rook to pin this bishop on
B6 and that's why Magnus defend it but
Knight can we get an analysis for it I
think Knight D4 is super instructive
giving up a minor piece in the center to
try to Checkmate the enemy King right
because if you take it then you go
Knight D5 attacking the queen and the
Knight if you take the Knight White's
going to recapture the queen is under
attack and you threaten Checkmate over
here so white wins and in case you play
Queen E6 then well you can take the
bishop but there's also all these E5
ideas with the IDE to to deliver
Checkmate over here so let's say if Y is
going to go for it he's he's just paused
and usually when pauses he comes up with
something interesting he's played H4
though oh and we see as the game
continues there are trades now and H4 it
earned a question mark because it wasn't
uh as quick as he needed to be and
Bishop takes E3 earned an exclamation
point now Benjamin as we see these moves
it looks like white still has potential
to attack but that Knight on E6 is such
a strong piece there's no longer Knight
F5 and that means that black is probably
out of the woods exactly the Knight
jumping to F5 really was the sting in uh
in Black's position Magnus just took
that out and now you cannot take the
pawn on G5 because if you take black has
Knight to G4 attacking the queen and
opening up this attack on the Knight and
so you lose a piece so here Magnus is
doing absolutely fine and now the time
is evened out so let's see how yon will
handle this situation and I think that
not only is Magnus doing fine you see
the Eva baring about zeros I kind of
like Black's position like right now
Knight H5 maybe we'll get a knight F4
and that's exactly what's happening and
G4 comes to mind at the right moment if
you want to go all in for the attack but
I just feel like Black's pieces are
Freer and that C3 Pawn that's the worst
single Pawn on the board yeah the pawn
on C3 is quite weak the pawn on D6 is
still weak as well but after Rook D1 you
can just defend with Rook to d8 also I
think if anything Magnus is more likely
to take advantage of the open H Hall he
can go King G7 followed by Rook to h8
Knight C5 and nice move by Magnus at
taking the PA E4 so yon just has to
slide back and here we go Robert King G7
you're on point right now uhoh Rook to
D1 is there a G4 coming I first defend
the D6 Pawn that looks too weak so it
goes Rook d8 G4 can happen next Rook h8
Queen H4 that will happen and it will
hurt and also Bishop A6 Knight E2 check
let's not forget about that yeah this
looks unpleasant for Yan he goes Bishop
to G3 one thing he has to one thing
Magnus has to be careful of is not a go
G4 too quickly is there might be some
Knight C5 tactics uh we see Queen to E3
all right this looks very tough for
jiannis I I don't see what he's going to
do and Magnus has this very easy plan of
going Queen F6 Queen H6 and Checkmate
along the H file so what is he going to
do after Queen F6 the queen H6 is next
he might have to after that put a knight
on H2 and pray that his Bishop on G3
holds everything together it looks bad
but I don't see the actual
breakthrough yeah know for sure but
Magnus has turned this one completely
around he seemed to be under a lot of
pressure he's got to speed up here
though he's dropping down to 40 seconds
he takes on F3 interesting decision I
guess now he wants to go Queen E6 move
Queen over to the H Hall as now there's
no longer Knight H2 and the Queen on E6
is better than the queen on F6 if King
F1 I first this checkm one but just in
general there's Queen C4 type of ideas
so the point the queen is staring in
both directions and that's why it's
probably a better Square than
F6 right we see y going Rook the one
perhaps clearing the way a little bit
for his King so now let's see what
Magnus is going to do so in case of
Queen H6 do we have Queen G4 he starts
with Rook to H6 wow what is the idea
behind this one I think he's just
defending the D6 PA so his Queen can go
to C4 A2 he's going to start going after
the White Queen side Queen B3 is an
option here the C3 Pawn is loose or
he'll Focus all his attention on the
king side but I don't know how to make a
Checkmate happen yeah Queen B3 good move
putting some pressure on upon on C3 all
right so let's see what what Jan is
going to do here it looks it looks
extremely tough I don't see an active
here for him anymore he goes one knight4
Knight 64 Magnus could just take this
palm and he goes for it that Queen is
overloaded and that's what the rook's
doing on H if Queen G4 there's always
Rook G6 to block the check oh Robert
look at this instead of Knight F6 he had
Queen digs D1 Rook H1 and leading to a
winning end game let's bring up an
analysis board if we can maybe let's
wait actually till the game ends and
then we'll pull up one after but that
was such a good find by you this still
looks good for Magnus if he gets his
Queen to h8 that's what he's aiming for
but look at how creative Yannis with his
defense he's maneuvered his Bishop from
F1 to D3 to F5 to H3 to block the H Hall
and now the pawn on D6 Magnus only has
two seconds wait take take and take5 he
just dropped his Central Pawn that is
unacceptable because now your winning
chances are not very high and this
position do you still think Magnus is
trying to win it I think so but I don't
think he should I mean Rook F5 do just
looks like a draw yeah Rook C1 check
King H2 Knight takes F2 there's no
Checkmate because Rook takes F4 gets rid
of the mating
Pawn what a what a throw by Magnus now
the game in draw so let's pulled it up
real quick Robert after Bishop to D 3
Mayers could have taken on D1 play Rook
H1 and take on F2 and at the end of it
oh and at the end of it all it would be
up I don't know at least two or is it
even three pawns yeah I think uh we got
the majority of it that was such a
beautiful tactic uh we've seen that by
some of the best players in the world
but so easy to miss because you have to
give up your queen and then realize you
can sacrifice your rook in the corner
temporarily being down a full Queen and
look at this speaking of no Queens on
the board Queen E2 Queen E7 what are are
we watching here
Benjamin we're watching the speed chest
Championship presented by coinbase but
this game isn't the most exciting so far
uh yeah pretty boring isn't this
something that Magnus played in the
world championship match when he wanted
to make a draw anyway we see KN p7 but
this check to be fair to Robert it looks
unpleasant for black white is very easy
piece play The King and of eight is kind
of stuck you can go G6 for the moment as
there's Bishop H6 check again we see the
kn95 move and it's not as easy for y to
bring his pieces into the game I'm with
you I mean these type of dry openings
they're highly criticized but it does
give Magnus I think the edge because Yan
prefers a more open board he is a
tactician he likes to play quickly but
in a position like this how can you play
quickly do you play F6 right now uh do
you play on The Queen side you can't
trade on E5 that much is clear and he
does go F6 but it's not easy to make
choices like this as they create
weaknesses E6 Square the F5 Square
not an easy
position yeah king of seven I think he's
done a good job crawling out of his
passive position now perhaps he can move
this bishop or move the Knight he still
has to bring the light Square Bishop
into the game so let's see how he will
try to do so Magnus has more space we
know how he can really be uh a how do
you a boa constrictor right he can
slowly but surely surround His position
tighten the screws we see G5 I think a
nice move by Yan grabbing some space on
the king side Magus could take but
that's going to open up the H for Yan
and this should be quite fine for black
but I think G5 was a critical move it
opened up some squares for his pieces
because Bishop F4 was going to happen
regardless and the instead of this there
could have been a white Pawn on F5 and
that would have just restricted Black's
pieces so Knight F5 Retreat of course
that's a good move defending the G6 Pawn
opening the light score Bishop Jan he
looked like he had a bit of a tough one
and yet he is able to neutralize most of
White's
Advantage yeah exactly Knight a five
nice move by y if he gets the
opportunity I think would love to go G5
kick the Knight away then develop his
bishop and go Rook E8 and then the
position should be quite even as the as
the as the pawn structure is symmetrical
so let's see what Magnus has to do I
think he has a couple of moves to try to
develop an initiative now G5 is not
possible as it allows Knight K G5
followed by Knight K D5 with a discovery
on the king and the Knight so what do
you do maybe King G7 Robert but then
there's Rook A1 and you turn to sign
into E7 moves like Rook R F1 are so nice
because they just create these problems
for your opponent now Rook a to E1 maybe
black has the plan to go Knight C to E6
remember everyone the Knight on f8 came
there not just to open up the light
squore Bishop but to protect the G6 Pawn
so Rook a to E1 Knight to E6 from the C7
Square I feel like black is doing a good
job and is a few moves away from being
completely stable Bishop D7 Rook E8
after that and finally black is
coordinated right so we'll try we'll see
how Magnus will try to build on this
initiative 96 nice move all right it's
not easy at all yet in case it takes you
can just
recapture so I I don't see it Robert
let's see how Magnus will will try to
work his magic here he's again down in
the clock Yan is always putting that
pressure it's not easy playing Yan the
pishi he's such a Speed Demon and here I
think strategically white doesn't really
want to trade on E6 and that's why
Knight D2 is if you take on F4 that's a
blunder because Rook E7 check will
happen first even if Knight takes D4
have that that pawn we already saw Yan
Goble up on D4 in the first game it
wasn't working out well for him he's
certainly not going to take it here yeah
I don't think so why not just to move
like Bishop to D7 develop the bishop
follow up with Rook to E8 and I think
black is doing absolutely fine and there
we go Rook Bishop to D7 so I don't know
Magnus seem to be having a slight
initiative but Jan has done a great job
at neutralizing it Jan has been very
steady today and with a one-point lead
right now the onus is on Magnus Carlson
to strike back at some moment but Jan is
looking relaxed I saw the feature chat
saying that but it's true he's leaning
back in his chair he's doing the rock
away and he's also developing his pieces
and just bringing his Rook to the
center yeah for sure I mean I guess Jan
also knows that he doesn't have a whole
lot to lose against Magnus Magnus of
course the Hefty favorite so you know if
he wins that'd be uh that'd be fantastic
if he loses you know it's um it it
happens you know you just um you just
move on so I guess there's not a whole
lot of pressure on him he knows what it
takes to beat Magnus he's beating Magnus
if I believe Le uh like four times in
classical chess so he knows what he has
to do that's correct and even though the
world championship didn't go his way I
think that it was great preparation for
him it was a great experience and a
second world championship didn't go his
way but it's clear that he's uh
improving in many different areas of the
game and one of them is being
increasingly solid playing the opening
like the Petro and he maintains in this
one an equal position and I don't see
much of anything here here Benjamin Yan
he may have been in the first game but
he's showing that he is not going to
break yeah for sure rookie a good move
bringing the Rook into the game now
Magnus finally defends the pawn as
Knight D4 was threatened so let's see
what Jan is going to do here maybe like
Knight G5 offer the trade of Rooks trade
everything off and black should be doing
absolutely fine in that end game that
being said though if all the Rooks come
off white can perhaps hope for a very
very small Edge as you have the
potential outside passer you also have
your pawns on darar and we have light
squar Bishops on the
board very very instructive points there
everyone please take note of what
Benjamin just said that because white
can create an outside pass Pawn certain
end games will be very nice especially
King and pawn end games because black
will be distracted towards the flank and
then white can operate more in the
center and the light Square Bishops
clearly favor white because of those
light Square pawns which means one that
white can attack Black's pawns and two
Black's Bishop is restricted so Magnus
might be counting on that but I also
wouldn't be surprised if one of them
offers a draw and the next couple moves
as all the Rooks come off the board it
would take a big mistake for someone to
lose this game yeah so we see 98 rookie
eight okay so here Magus is going to
trade go King and there we have that
move H4 Robert he wants to create that
outside pass I guess now you go G3 Jon
isn't too eager to trade like we said
that outside passer will give white some
very small chances but knet of7 on the
board very solid move I think he's
headed to D6 followed by Bishop G6 and
so his Knight can potentially go to F5
this should be a comfortable hold for y
I think it should be but we've said that
so many times when Magnus Carlson is
playing someone should make a draw it
looks like Yan just offered a draw and
Magnus declined it by playing take on G5
so a draw was offered Magnus not
interested and this still looks very
level Bishop G6 a nice move here by y
Pawn on G5 was under attack but for the
moment you cannot take it as your Bishop
on D3 is hanging and if you trade on G6
first well then the King on G6 defends
the pawn so nice move it puts the bishop
on a more active diagonal we see the
trade here Robert I think this one is
going to end in a draw pretty soon the
position is completely symmetrical
there's nothing to attack right the
Knight on D6 protects the B7 Pawn if the
Knight comes to C4 for black well you
can play B3 and the king is marching
toward the center let me ask you
Benjamin did Magnus decline because he
might want the quicker time controls
where he feels like he's even more of a
favorite do you think he's sort of
wasting some match clock even in just
the first few
games yeah I don't know it's a good it's
a good question on the other hand though
he is behind so he should won more games
in a match I would think from Yan's
perspective a draw like milking out the
clock here is not a bad idea again you
you get less games in the match so I I
think Magnus perhaps should resign
himself to a draw here sooner rather
than later there's just nothing to be
done right the Knight on E5 protects G4
the Knight that was on e4 protected G5
there's nothing to go after here uh I
think both players they know it's a draw
and yet Magnus he always finds some
chances look at this C5 does he want
King D3 King C3 B4 it's not going to
happen right there's no way and he had
to move his Knight back CU Knight takes
C5 was a threat there so is Magnus
really playing for a win here or is he
just shuffling
about yeah I don't know what to make of
this move Knight C3 though I don't know
why y didn't just go back to F6 it looks
very natural now Magnus can play the
move Knight F2 cutting off the return to
D4 Square yon however can go Knight A2
to B4 so he's still doing absolutely
fine but I don't know like the thing
with Magnus is that the evil bar is
always in the middle but at some point
it's slowly but surely is going to creep
up that's because the Eva bar doesn't
take into context how difficult it feels
to play a position a big issue right now
for Magnus is he would love to attack
the A5 Pawn but his Knight doesn't have
a single Square on the board where I can
attack it from Knight takes C5 Robert
Knight takes C5 oh did they was there
Knight takes no there was not even
Knight take C6 there so that was a Miss
by real quick Knight C5 was a big
opportunity for y in case you take you
win the Knight and Knight C6 there's
there's knight4 o so somehow the Eva Bar
says that's not even that impressive
regardless U so Knight takes C5 still
maybe had drawing chances but you can't
miss those if you're Magnus you can't
allow it and if you're Yan you need to
find that
moment exactly now we see a trade on B4
yon trades and I think this is just
headed for a draw the King goes to C7
and there nothing for either side to do
so okay if you're Yan here if you're Yan
here do you just milk out the clock I
guess well he
doesn't no he he just makes the draw by
repetition I think for both players it's
kind of uncomfortable to stall this
early in the match you just don't feel
like you're in the rhythm of the games
and yand pomi two to one advantage right
now he gets the white pieces he goes
back to E4 and we're getting a I think
we're going to get another fight in this
game
too M all right and so we have the
Sicilian Four Knights here yon has a
couple of decisions he can go Knight DB5
that could turn the game back into his
fov but he went for Knight C6 the other
Main Line Magnus recaptured with the
pawn and then E5 Knight E4 and we see
the move C5 by Magnus ignoring the
threat on the Knight but attacking the
Knight on
e4 this is such a fun opening position
because my first instinct would be to
play Knight D6 check and if the bishop
takes D6 I'd want to take with the queen
but I can't because Knight C2 Fork at
the end I don't want to take on D6 with
a pawn and he's going for this exact
line and that pawn Benjamin do you see
it as a strength or a weakness because
it is very deep in enemy camp yeah it's
a great question Robert the good thing
also about this Pawn on D6 is that this
Pawn on C5 is practically isolated after
Bishop E3 there's no such move s D6 here
so it's going to be awkward to defend so
what exactly is Magnus going to do here
you can defend it temporarily with Queen
A5 but white just goes Queen D2 offers
the the trade of queens and again this
Pawn is terribly weak so not easy to
deal with this for for Magnus and hey
we've talked about this yesterday do you
think there is a chance that jannis
looked at this for the World Chess
Championship because again for that
match I'm sure he's checked every single
opening Under the
Sun Jan's preparation has proven
excellent and he probably has looked at
something like this for the world
championship Queen F6 played by Magnus
so he defends tactically he's not
actually protecting the C5 Pawn but he
says it's it's going to be an equal
trade one for one give me your B2 Pawn
your king feels less safe and if you
play a move like Rook to B1 some kind of
slow move I think that black has Knight
to D4 even now after Queen D2 Knight
sits on D4 please take me I'll have E5
to follow it up and that D6 Pawn that we
were talking about it's no longer an
argument that one will be vulnerable but
look at how yon deals with it he he
trades on D4 and goes queenside castles
and how do you defend the pawn on D4 if
you go E5 white is going to blast up the
structure with the move F4 and your
Center is falling apart yon's doing
great here do F4 is such a good find and
that way if you take the D4 Pawn the D6
Pawn remains alive and that would be an
issue so suddenly Magnus in some danger
here Yan's preparation has been good
should black you think just Castle King
side give up the D4 pawn and eventually
go after the white
king I mean you can try the king is
sitting pretty safe over here the pawn
C4 is providing a nice Shield the king
can always move over with like King B1
King A1 potentially
I don't know it's looking tough for
Magnus the annoying thing for him is
that after E5 F4 Queen dick D6 Pawn di
C5 Queen di C5 there is the move Rook e
on so he is going to go down a pawn here
although there's Bishop E4 at the end of
that variation with maybe an F5 but look
at this Magnus gives up the pawn in the
center and Yan looks confused he's like
are are you sure about that Queen takes
D4 a queen Swap and Magnus Carlson
saying yes you're up a pawn but the A3
B2 Pawn combination there one pawn stops
two and maybe there will be a way for
him to go Rook A5 Castle bring the other
Rook into the game and just completely
freeze White's pawns yeah if Magnus
could get all of those moves in he's
perhaps doing all right so let's see
what Jon is going to do in the meantime
perhaps he can just go Rook to G1 or he
might even have to protect this Pawn
because in case Magnus takes there is
the move Rook G1 attacking the bishop
and you regain the pawn on G7 so I guess
now is a good time for Magnus to Castle
here or play Move Like F5 gaining some
space in the center followed by by King
F7 King F6 and then you can go for the
settle with Bishop C6 Rook A5 Rook B8
and you have some sort of blocking on
the queen side so it might not be that
bad Magnus Carlson may not believe in
fortresses but it looks like he has one
in this game so he plays F6 which
apparently is not recommended by the
engines I think the engines they're a
bit harsh in the sense that objectively
it was not the best move there was
something better there maybe Magnus had
a castle quickly to protect the G7 Pawn
that threatens G2 then you bring the
Rook to the C file but F6 looks like a
very natural move from the number one
rated player of the world exactly he
wants to go King to F7 bring his King up
to the board so then he can go Rook to
B8 then Bishop C6 I guess Rook A5 it's
all looking pretty solid C5 by yon a
nice move he wants to go perhaps Bishop
B5 and go after this spawn A4 I I like
what he's doing he's not allowing Magnus
to consolidate here well now that
actually explains why F6 was a mistake
because it allowed white to play C5 and
look at the eval bar it's going up more
and more in White's favor that's going
to be a pass Pawn on D6 now that D7 is
removed but Benjamin I look at this I
still feel like Magnus has very good
chances to hold but how could you not
like White's position the A4 Pawn is
loose as well yeah this looks great for
Yan he is now in check so I guess he has
to go King B1 or King D2 the pawn at A4
is about to drop he's got this pass Pawn
D6 H but yeah if he takes the PA E4 he
will have two connected passers on the
queen side this is looking very problem
for Magnus Robert and if Magnus loses
this game he will go down two points in
a
match and that could be a dream come
true for Yan Naomi and a nightmare for
Magnus you don't want Jan to feel the
rhythm as soon as he starts feeling good
about his chest we know how dangerous a
confident Yan pom is he's run away with
the candidat tournament he won before
the even the final round was played so
do not give Yan this confidence right
now how could he not be confident with
that D6 Pawn to two squares away from
promotion exactly yeah so let's see what
mag is going to do you can take on G2
but I suppose you just go Rook E1 taking
the pawn on E6 and once you go E5 then
you take on e4 and it's so annoying for
Magnus that for the moment this D6 Pawn
remains on the board this this is
looking super tough and again Robert
look at the clock Yan again up a minute
Yan naami he continues to do well on the
clock and mnus Carlson he looks kind of
upset right now he does attack this Rook
on D4 that's the good news but when The
Rook just slid over to E4 this A4 Pawn
at the end of it is going to be loose
but Yan apparently made a mistake Rook
to G1 the very natural move was that
wrong
somehow I think he played way too
quickly here after E5 why did he first
of all not take an A4 and after Bish
Bish takes G2 I think he should also
have considered to move Rook to D1 now
Magnus might be out of the woods there's
a check but King E6 black should be
doing absolutely fine here cuz the Rooks
finally get active it looks so scary to
allow two Rooks on the the seventh rank
but the Kings already escaped the back
rank so there's not going to be a
Checkmate and suddenly you know we've
seen this so many times can Magnus
Carlson play for more he's going to have
the active King he's going to bring a
rook of his own down to the second Rank
and if he can get both of his Rooks in
the first rank we could even see a back
ranked Checkmate threat thanks to that
pawn on A4 I think this is actually a
position all three results are
possible exactly yeah know Theon on A4
would freeze the Viking on A2 so that be
pretty tough for for Yan also these
pawns on F2 and H2 are weak your
majority on the queen side for the
moment is quite useless so I think
Magnus is doing absolutely fine like you
said he has the potential to even play
here for a wi he goes Pawn to D7 Yan all
right so let's see what Magnus is going
to do here maybe G5 preserving the G
Pawn or just going Rook to D6 but Rook
D6 is meant by Rook takes G7 so that
would keep that pawn on the board so he
does play your first move G5 that's a
great choice and this is why I believe
that this position has has chances for
both sides to win D7 remains but look at
Black's extra pawns on the king side
it's four on two on that side of the
board and the Eva bar suddenly is
favoring black cuz Rook C4 and that Rook
can start going after those white
pawns yeah we see Rook a six check by by
Yan but yeah Magnus has a lot of
potential here on the king side he can
go let's say Rook F4 or Rook H4 going
after the pawn H2 and yon for the moment
does not have a single active he the the
great thing here for Mangus is that he
can let take go H4 and he doesn't need
to rush but with going Rook takes H2 he
can go H5 first as yon has to keep an
eye on this Pawn he also has to keep
defending the on D7 so I don't know has
Magnus turned this one completely around
he has indeed that's a good move though
Rook to D3 instead of Defending
passively cuz Rook F4 he'll play Rook H3
and Target that loose H7 Pawn I really
like Rook to D3 and I think for black
Benjamin the move you've been shouting
for H5 that looks very strong because
White's main IDE aidea is Rook H3 and if
you go Rook F3 black can always play
Rook F4 and trade the Rooks on that
square to protect the vulnerable F6 Pawn
Yeah H5 looks like a nice move like you
said for the moment Rook H3 is a big
threat for Yan and there we have Magnus
is so precise in the end game and I
don't know Robert holding this game
would already be a big big success right
now for Yan whereas before it looked
like he was on his way to another
Victory it's a turnaround just like in
game one where Magnus he had the upper
hand with the white pieces and suddenly
Jon was able to steal a bishop in the
game now Jan has to figure it out where
he was first better and now he's to make
that switch in his mind so we have Rook
F3 on the board Rook F4 looks very
strong to me if Rook takes G takes F4
and look at Black's pawns they're
marching up very very quickly there
they're going to be
dangerous exactly but what about this
idea Robert what about Rook takes D7 and
if you take on F6 you can give a check
King A2 and Rook C1 and Magnus is going
down wait check and Rook Rook D1
W oh that actually was a mating net
potentially so maybe there's a way out
there for white but this looks great for
black the Eva bar is all the way down
because White's King is cut off Benjamin
it doesn't matter about the pawn
quantity I say this often in the end
game go take the H5 Pawn I don't care
but what king E6 Pawn E4 how are you
stopping these
passers I don't see it just go Rook F2
here Jon can go after the pawn A4 but it
will be super slow look at this Robert
Jon is up a PA but his majority on the
queen side is completely Frozen his Rook
on H3 is frozen his King on B1 is
completely stuck this is a dominant
position for Magnus Carlson and what is
he aiming for it's Black's turn King to
E3 just winning the F3 but it's Rook H5
potentially so you need to be a little
bit precise here he plays E4 because
it's again not about the quantity it's
about the quality the F Pawn is hard to
stop exactly yeah it's very difficult to
make a move here for Yan if you go Rook
to h8 then then Magnus can now go Rook
G2 followed by F2 and you can't quite
stop that pawn you can also create any
counterplay over here again you're
completely Frozen on the queen side this
so Magnus looks to be on his way to
another Victory here Magnus Carlson the
best endgame player of all time adding
another one to his storybook career he
just knows when to liquidate he knows
what pawn formations are best for him
and right now he knows that he's going
to even up this match two to2 Benjamin I
don't think we could have asked for more
from these first four games no for sure
and it will be interesting to see how
yon will deal with this we know that
sometimes he can go on tilt and this can
be quite a tilting loss he had a good
position perhaps a winning position out
of the opening and instead of instead of
winning he did not only throw away the
win but then he also threw away the draw
and Magnus has now evened up the score
and I think the good news for Yan after
that loss is it is halim Midway through
the time controls they get a break so we
have seen 45 minutes of action the score
is two to2 both players talking to the
team behind the scenes and we see it
here with that Victory nope it's not one
to2 you're going to see that update live
in front of you that will be two to2
score yand pomi Magnus Carlson they're
evened up exactly Magnus with his first
win of the match I think he cannot be
too unhappy Yan could have also won this
game with the white pie he had a winning
position but yon perhaps played a little
bit too
quickly yes he he did bring us uh to a
tie with a 2-2 score and Magnus Carlson
he can be happy once more he's taking on
yand pomi for a trip to the semi finals
here at the Spees Championship presented
by coinbase more in just a
[Music]
few
I'm Andrea and I'm Alex and we've been
playing competitive chess since we were
6 years
old we started by focusing on classical
chess but later we fell in love with
playing Blitz and bullet
online chess has been around for more
than 1,000 years but that doesn't mean
that we can't modernize it Financial
systems have been around for even longer
sounds like it's time for an update and
coinbase is doing just that
reenvisioning an entirely new Financial
system that is decentralized and fully
transparent also huge thank you to
coinbase for sponsoring competitive
chess and making events like the SEC
happen go to coinbase.com updatethe
system to learn
more September Bots are here and it's
time for a Monumental Clash this B
Barbarian might not Crush you on the
board but he certainly can Crush you
with the board speaking of crushing this
giant is a living Siege Tower usually
found in groups goblins are fond of
sharp pointy objects and other people's
pieces the battle Harden Valkyrie might
give you a game once she's done arm
wrestling a
Golem this hog rider and his Noble Steed
might give you a headache or two
skeletons adore her but Fara you'll need
to bring your aame if you want to beat
this witch yes that probably is a rabbit
up his sleeve or a huge Fireball with
your name on it we hear Wizards are
pretty good at chess not just a killing
machine Pekka loves tiny butterflies but
you're probably not a butterfly so watch
out the Archer Queen thinks highly of
herself and for good reason she's a
skilled tactician deadly opponent and
your worst nightmare play them all on
chess.com
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
welcome back to the 2023 speed chest
Championship presented by coinbase we
have a 22 deadlock right now in the
match up between Magnus Carlson and Yan
Naomi Yanna pomi he's no stranger to
Magnus Carlson he's no stranger to the
speed chest Championship back in 2019 he
ended up in the semi-finals before he
was eliminated by hiard Nakamura but
Benjamin he beat dingly Ren along the
way in addition to having the biggest
margin in SEC history in his win over
Lena
danilon exactly yeah he beat D Ren in
the match I'm sure he would have loved
to beat ding in another match that took
place this year and I'm sure you also
would have loved to beat Magnus in
another match a couple years ago but
he's had he had he's having his chance
here for revanche Robert he um the score
right now is even same as in the world
championship for quite a while so let's
see how he will deal with this uh this
loss perhaps the break came at a good
time for him it gives him some time to
recuperate it feels a little bit a
little bit unnecessary to lose that one
as he could have also won yeah he did
have a great position after he stole a
dewn had a passer of his own but Magnus
Carlson does what Magnus does best he
wins end games even unwinable looking
ones so yand pomi he does have his work
cut out for him having an even score
right now is a good thing and I believe
Benjamin that he needs to stay in that
even margin if he goes down in this
match that's where it's dangerous
because Magnus Carlson we know how
difficult he is to beat once try to beat
him several times in a row I wish you
the best of luck yeah for sure I think
though the Yan gives himself the best
Chance by going up a game or two holding
on to that lead for as long as possible
and hoping that Magnus will get a little
bit nervous but if Magnus takes the lead
I think it's going to be smooth sailing
for him so let's see how the next couple
of games will go and we are about to
have liftoff in the fifth game of the 5
minute plus 1 second increment time
control there's Yan theom
and here are the opening moves we have
Knight F3 from Magnus in this game so
instead of our E4 e5s and pets and
turning into frenches we have an
English exactly and here to move E3 an
interesting move by Magus I wonder what
exactly he has in mind in case yon plays
the move D5 perhaps he wants to play
something like Knight of C3 so let's see
what Yan will do here you can also go
for a set of with B6 and there we have
the move B D5 and now the move B3 by
Magnus
and he's just trying to fan ketto on
this long diagonal staring towards the
black king and in these positions
sometimes white is able to hand black
and isolate a Pawn on the D file but
inste we see D4 so we have the box all
these pawns staring at each other so
Benjamin in this opening do you like
black or do you typically like this from
White I think black's doing pretty well
here he takes D4 is a nice move by Yan
he could take on C4 and after Magnus
recaptures play a move like A6 followed
by B5 and Bishop B7 and it's turning
into a bit of a Queen's Gambit accepted
but I think black is a pretty reasonable
version the N C3 is often a little bit
misplaced as it's blocking the bishop on
the long diagonal and very often you
would rather have it on D2 so let's see
what Y is going to do I think this this
approach with D4 and A6 is very solid
it's becoming sort of a Queen's Gambit
accepted type of position and the big
part of these type of structures is that
black has some weak squares the C6
Square in particular and we see the
light Square Bishops coming off and Rook
to A7 play but I think white should take
on B7 put a queen on F3 put a rook on C1
and D1 and that C6 square is tender and
black needs to look out for it exactly
I'm a little bit surprised by the move
Rook to A7 by Yan I think he would have
also addressed the issue with Queen B6
that's what he does now but had he
played Queen B6 on the last move he
could have already played Knight but D7
or Knight C6 and he should be doing
completely fine now Magnus might have a
move or two to create some problems for
y but if he doesn't do anything quickly
I think Jan is going to be doing
absolutely fine here with KN bd7 coming
on the next move a problem for white is
that all of the pieces look like they're
in pretty optimal squares you need to
look where to improve the Rook on F1
that's the one piece but Rook to E2 that
looks a bit silly so maybe Queen E2 Rook
D1 something like that it does feel
though as you said that black is in time
so Knight to E2 he's opening the C file
it's about that C6 Square potentially
and what do you make of this yeah so we
see trade on F3 I think magnus's idea
was that in case yon would have played
Knight B D7 there would have been Knight
C6 and that is why yon traded first now
he goes Knight C6 bring his Knight into
the game I think Robert you've
highlighted you've highlighted this
before Magnus is going to try to apply
pressure on that C6 Square he goes Queen
to C2 pressuring the Knight maybe a
knight to D4 jump in the near future so
Jan still has a few problems to solve
here Rook C8 would be a big blunder
Bishop D4 would be a winning tactic
because the Knight is is pinned to The
Rook so Rook C8 would not be a good move
even though it looks like a normal one
to protect that Knight Rook C7 is
possible because Bishop D4 after Rook C7
you can actually take that piece because
their tactics on the E2 Square so you
need to time these things correctly if
you are both these players but right now
Yan needs to avoid any sort of tactics
that lose him some material he walks
right into it
four oh my
gosh Robert you cannot do this you if
you're playing Magnus you can of make
blunders like this oh my God we just
spoke about it the Knight on C6 is
pinned because of the back rank check
and Yan he looks up at the ceiling but
there is no Beth Harman Solutions here
he's unfortunately going to lose this
game this is just clean
material yeah he's down a very clean
exchange Queen B1 by Magnus now he's
just going to trade up some pieces what
a blunder by Yan pishi he could have
just played Rook to C7 and then like you
said there would have always been these
tactics with taking on D4 and Tak on too
but now he's down in exchange and Robert
I think he we've talked about this
before if you want to have a chance
against bangus you cannot blunder like
this and you also you canot just throw
games that was an even looking position
and now he is just down a rook for a
bishop there's an open file if the
position were a bit more closed maybe we
would say that black had chances of
course if he had a pawn and a bishop for
The Rook then sure but it's a clean
exchange Rook for Bishop there's an open
C file Rook C1 here looks very promising
Benjamin this should be a onesided
finish yeah 92 a nice move by Magnus now
he's just going to move a rook to C1
Queen C2 trade of the queens and you can
already pretty much resign here if
you're y the pish she very unfortunate
loss that seemed I mean there was a
little bit of pressure by Manus but yeah
he just had some he just had to find a
couple of accurate moves to solve all of
it it was just a careless move there he
just wasn't looking for tactics he was
looking for positional pressure and look
at this move Queen E4 Magnus even when
he is winning positions he continues to
be precise that Knight wanted to land on
C3 to close down the C5 maybe get a pass
Pawn now that Knight is pinned the queen
on B7 has to stay put tied down to the
C8 square and look at this maneuvering
you can trade on C3 if you want he says
no Queen on A6 protects it all E2 and A2
beautiful instructive play from Magnus
Carlson yeah great St here by Magnus
young goes Pawn to G6 he still has do he
still has that Knight on C3 I guess now
he's going to recapture with the pawn
queen D3 I think if Magnus get that's
the opportunity he's probably going to
give up his Rook for the pawn Rook C2
Magnus is winning here but how do you
actually convert this Robert there
there's still some work to be done and I
wonder if Magnus has completely mapped
this out where he recognizes that
certain end games if he takes on C3 and
even if he's only at one Pawn in the que
end game it's winning cuz he just has
that kind of knowledge but here in this
position he might bring his King to help
out in the center Queen to C4 that takes
care of everything B3 will be defended
and that's C3 Pawn it's going to be
surrounded exactly and now he can go
Queen to C4 King E2 and he should win
this game pretty easily so let's see
what yon is going to try to do here
maybe King G7 moving the king up a
little bit there there's nothing black
can do yon just has to sit and wait here
and wait for Magnus to show him how you
know this game is won now I think Rook
C3 is a good way to make things a lot
easier for white and there we go just
two extra pawns over there on the queen
side this is one where if the white king
could be checked bunch of times maybe
you have a chance but at this stage King
oh King E2 might actually have some
problems with the g2 Pawn being targeted
so it's not as easy as it would
initially appear
perhaps yeah still some work to be done
for Magnus he goes King E2 okay now I
guess Queen D5 like you pointed out for
yon hitting that pawn on G2 which is
awkward to defend you can go for the
move F3 but then there's Queen G5
although I guess then there's King F1 so
Magus should be winning winning here in
many different ways even just A5 he goes
F3 so I guess after Queen G5 here he is
going to go for the move King
F1 yeah it's then you don't see too many
more checks even here Queen G3 check so
what king to F1 the problem is that the
black queen needs to be in three
different locations at once it needs to
be on H1 but it also go back to G3 when
the King goes to F2 you just can't get
everything there Whit's pawns go up the
board Magus Carlson is going to take his
first lead in this match exactly B4 he's
just pushing the pawns up slowly but
surely King G8 Yan just shuffling back
and forth there's nothing he can do just
perhaps just B5 here or queen D4 another
nice move offering the trade of Queens
but also taging this Pawn on H4 and if
you take the pawn on H4 black never has
any Perpetual ideas anymore that's true
the king can slink away to the H2 Square
eventually and you just block a check on
the diagonal so Magnus is up three Pawns
in a queen end game a few checks that's
about it so yand pal she resigns and
Magnus Carlson up three to two Benjamin
here is the ultimate test for Yan he now
has lost a couple games uh uh oh he's
playing a Kings game I was about to say
can he rebound or is he going to tilt
he's going for I need to win right now
exactly yeah well this is also what he
played against me in title Tuesday this
week when he was in a must-win situation
in the last round we see Magnus
repeating I think this is also what
Magnus played against hiara Kamura and
Norway chess Jan going for Knight of two
he's still playing Super quickly so
perhaps he's looked at this before the
match and Yan he returns to openings
from his childhood right these Kings
Gambit he plays the French defense is
black he's not afraid to play offbeat
lines but the problem with this
particular opening is White's King is in
the center Rook G8 earned an exclamation
point going to the open file maybe
there's Rook G3 to come and it just
feels like black is the one having the
fun at least for the time being exactly
yeah black is easy development uh the
bishop kind of move out the ponent E4 is
tender so I don't know it feels like
this this king's Gambit has backfired
quite a bit I I remember also Norwich
has when Hikaru tried to King his gamb
against Magnus Magnus was not in trouble
for a single moment in the game he knows
quite well how to tackle it look at this
position the G2 Pawn is loose so the
bishop on F1 can't develop the E4 Pawn
is attacked and also pinned so not only
will there be tactics on the Square and
he was Queen to B3 I'm still liking the
look of Rook to G3 because that also
threatens Knight takes D4 here I I just
said it earlier but now it carries an
additional threat rookie three check's
going to hurt this looks like another
potential one-sided game for Magnus I
think if he just goes on the offensive
Jan is going to be
hurting yeah I like this move Rook G3
that you pointed out that it does
threaten to move Knight takes D4 it also
introduces this idea of Rook to E3 check
and the King has to perhaps go to D1 you
can go Bishop E2 but then you're in a
pin so it looks great so far for Magus
the material is even white is completely
tied up you cannot develop a single
piece and there we see Robert Rook to
G3 it's so unfortunate for Yan he's
pinned along the third rank his King is
stuck in the center and when I mentioned
Rook G3 several moves ago it's just
because that pawn is up on H4 one of the
bad things about pushing pawns is you
give away key squares so Black's Pawn
structure looks compromised with double
F pawns but Benjamin we see that you get
counterplay around it whenever you have
double pawns you have open files there's
an open E file there's an open G file
there may be these isolated pawns the f
file but that is not what's important
it's King safety and the aggressive
intentions are all in Black's
favor yeah and I already don't see what
yon should do here Knight Tak D4 is a
very clear threat perhaps you have to
move your queen but he's just moved it
so is he going to move it again with
like Queen A4 but black just goes Bishop
to D7 black almost has all of their
pieces into the game white only has
these two knights developed your king is
stuck in the middle it's very difficult
to develop the Bishops so is yon perhaps
already a little bit on Ted
Robert playing the king's Gambit was a
sign to me that maybe he was does he
really believe in the Kings Gambit
that's another question but against
Magnus Carlson I would not be playing
such a risky opening it's backfiring
completely as you mentioned the the pin
on the third rank if the queen moves I
don't even know where he move to if the
queen goes to C2 for example then Knight
D5 into E3 is just another idea that I
could go for the pawn on e4 is pinned
and oh my goodness this looks
miserable this looks super tough for yon
and what really indicates that he is
struggling here is the clock usually y's
up on time but now he's almost down one
and a half minutes on the clock he goes
Knight at F3 hanging Pawn on e4 can
Magnus just take it I actually like this
decision he's going to swap Knights I
believe and then he's going to try to
tuck his King away there's not another
check in the position but look at Magnus
Bishop E6 giving up B7 he doesn't care
about a single Pawn he wants to go after
that white king So Benjamin it's all
about timing and B7 should not be
captured and look at this variation
Robert if Magnus grabs his Pawn on B7
Magnus wants to go Rook B8 attacking to
Queen and if you take on C7 there Rook
takes B2 and if you take the Rook
there's Queen E3 Checkmate so Magnus for
sure cannot take this Pawn but then
where is he going to go with the queen
that is such a beautiful line if you
can't take on B7 because a tactic The
Rook takes B2 check then you probably
just have to move your queen to D1 no he
plays Bishop to
C4 can you I want to take and play
Knight E5 but I'm not sure if it works
it probably
does yeah it it I assume it does cuz you
canot take a the pawn at the queen on C4
and if you take the Knight you hang the
pawn of G2 with devastating effect so
what do you do queen B5 but maybe then
just C6 followed by Knight D3 or or
something yeah that looks crushing
Robert it looks like it's going to be a
swift victory for Magnus he's doing the
right thing by calculating right now
about Bishop takes C4 followed by Knight
to E5 it's very direct it's one
attacking move after another you hit the
queen when the queen gives you a check
you hit the queen again oh he castles
Queen side instead and I can hardly
blame him Knight E5 still a threat the
white king not very safe at all that
looks this looks terrible for white Rook
to G8 is coming attacking the pawn on G2
Yan has still has not completed his
development and his King is super weak
on F2 so the king's Gambit has backfired
tremendously the King has been Gambit it
that King is going to be stolen and
black is going to Checkmate it and it's
going to be another win for Magnus that
would be three in a row and I don't know
how Yan is going to bounce back from
that but King's Gambit is not the answer
and there we have to move Knight to E5
you cannot take to D Pawn you hang your
queen and again if you take the Knight
you hang the pawn on G2 so there's
nothing here for there's nothing here
for Jan I mean you're going to have to
move the queen then black can take on F3
with a rook or with a knight and black
just gets a crushing attack and black is
even up upon and Magnus takes a
two-point lead resignation was the only
solution to that position can't look at
it anymore Magnus Carlson up four games
to two and now with the white pieces
Magnus he's going to his fian ketto
setup and will he go to a Catalin that's
the big question no he instead goes to a
king's Indian
attack yeah and he goes for this move A4
quite a funny little move I wonder what
exactly the IDE is we see yon playing
the move Knight C6 very quickly he can
now go E5 grab space in the center but
Robert it's going to be interesting to
see how yon will deal with all of this I
mean he lost that game with a white
pieces Magnus came back and yeah now
he's losing game after
game and look at this position here it's
one where it's a solid position for both
sides and that tends to favor Magnus
against anybody on the planet so Black's
position great opening thus far from Yan
he is not worse you see the eval bar
right down the middle and he can't
afford to beat himself playing the
king's Gambit like that it's what you
were talking about yesterday Benjamin
where you play some kind of risky
opening he lost in 13 moves to arjin he
lost a pretty quick one to Magnus and
what just happened there why did the
evelar go all the way down for a
second so it seems that Rook the might
have been a Miss I think yon had the
opportunity to go B6 followed by Bishop
to A6 which would have been very
uncomfortable for Magus to deal with as
where do you go with the queen right you
cannot go to E3 going back to E1 looks
quite passive you can go Knight C4 but
then you're pinned and if you go C4 then
you create a lot of weak squares now yon
goes for Bishop to G4 also a nice move
as he can potentially take control over
the square on D4 and he protected his E5
Pawn which is under Threat by three
pieces at least before white played C3
because the pin on that F3 Knight so C3
play to stop that Knight D4 move you
talked about the bishop on B2 looks
quite silly it's funny playing an
opening like this where it looks like
white is not doing anything right and
yet the Eva bar is saying it's
completely fine for Magnus he gets away
with these type of openings because
objectively they're just
fine exactly Yana's doing absolutely
fine here he goes Queen E6 stepping the
queen up a little bit I think the reason
why white is doing fine here is because
this KN on C6 does doesn't have anywhere
to go to for the moment the pa the
squares on B4 and D4 are restricted on
the other hand the KN on C4 is quite
active it can potentially move around to
E3 and D5 or F5 so we see to move Rook
F1 by Magnus I wonder exactly what he
has in mind and also does Bishop on B2
for the moment it looks silly but it can
always reroute via C1 to E3 or G5 this
likely to happen and Bishop H3 one of
Black's main ideas when you line the
queen and Bishop up is not possible
because the Knight G5 jumps with a Fork
of Queen and Bishop so Rook to E1
protecting the E4 pawn overprotecting it
you could say and maybe he'll SCE Queen
back to F1 at some point and then play
H3 himself and just try to kick this
bishop out of
there right so let's see what Yan's
going to do here's he takes a little bit
of time he goes Knight to E8 I think a
nice move he wants to go Knight to D6 to
try to to try to trade off this active
Knight on C4 so now if Magnus wants to
keep this Knight on the board perhaps he
has to consider move like Queen to C2 so
he can meet Knight D6 with Knight three
uh cuz otherwise after the trade it
feels like young gets a pretty
comfortable position you can always
recapture with a rook move the other
Rook to d8 and then perhaps try to
infiltrate a Magnus goes H3 and Robert
you've talked about this before this
Pawn is not hanging because of Knight G5
so that's a very nice move then but I
still think that your ideas are nice for
black Bishop takes F3 you have to take
with the queen so you don't drop a Pawn
on H3 and then Knight to D6 and the
problem for white is that B3 Pawn is so
tender you play the move C2 to C3 I
think one of White's best ideas is to
push that pawn back grab it back to C2
to keep your Pawn in a chain and thus
protect
it exactly so let's see what Jana's
going to do here he can trade on F3
Bishop H5 also very logical keeping the
pin on the Knight Rook 81 by Magnus and
now perhaps it's time to go for that
move Knight to D6 what you can also do
Robert is go F6 followed by Bishop to F7
to reroute that bishop and put some
pressure on the PA B3 but knight6 was
chosen by Yan I like the look of this
for black it's starting to appear very
solid I think that if Magnus wants to
play for more at some point he might
need to throw in G4 and wow Rook D5
you're hitting the bishop on C5 you're
stopping the Queen's stare to C4 and B3
and you're also threatening the E5 Pawn
with another piece so G4 suddenly might
be a pretty big
threat yeah so let's see what Yan's
going to do he takes on C4 I suppose
that Magnus is just going to recapture
because if you take the bishop black can
take on B2 and she'll be doing
absolutely fine and there we see
recapture by Magnus but great Point
Robert if you move the bishop to the
wrong Square perhaps this Pawn on E5 can
be hanging in some variations also
Robert in case of let's say Bishop to f8
there might be a rook takes d8 and if
you take the Rook then white can trade
on D6 and give you double isolated Pawn
so maybe you have to play Bishop to D6
wow process of elimination that pays off
for yand pomi good call by you Benjamin
that looked like a very bad end game for
black so Bishop D6 keeps all the pieces
on the board I still like the look of G4
for white espe especially because E4 is
defended so many times it's not like
you're inviting the bishop onto a
particularly nice square and then white
can consider Knight H4 and either take
that Bishop on G6 or bring the Knight to
F5 so maybe Knight H4 now makes sense G4
first I'm not sure which is superior but
either way I do think that Knight on F3
needs to
improve exactly so let's see what Magnus
is going to do if yon gets another move
here he might have the time to go Knight
E7 attack that Rook on D5 and once The
Rook slides back he can take a C4 and
Rune White's Pawn stru so Magnus has to
be a little bit careful here and that is
why he's investing some time so let's
see what he's going to do it's such an
important variation that this KN E7 is a
threat it would be bad news for the
white Pawn structure and that Bishop on
B2 which is looking particularly useless
so what to do here maybe I can't go
Bishop F1 I almost hung a piece but he
goes Knight D2 same idea that way the
queen is defended on C4 by a piece
rather than just a
pawn exactly so now kn7 can just be met
with Rook D3 and in case you take white
can recapture with the Knight so Robert
what about this idea right here F6
followed by Bishop F7 bring the bishop
back into the game although it's not
it's not bad over here but I think the
bishop can have more effect on this
diagonal there's such an important point
that Rook takes D6 here uh this he was
not available because the black work
would have taken back to defend the
Queen instead we see the Queens come off
the board and what is this ending white
gets a pair of Bishops but black gets
the open defile oh or not so fast
closing that defile after Bishop F7 Rook
D6 cd6 who do you think that
transformation of Pawn structure will
favor it's a good question Robert I feel
like black should be doing fine here we'
see him move Rook 88 by Yan and Bishop
A3 played quickly by Magnus Rook to D7
if Yan gets another move here Bishop F7
he's kicking The Rook away but Bishop F1
great move by Magnus he's rerouting the
bishop to C4 or B5 and all of a sudden
there's all these pins lurking into
position and I'm looking at the clock
and we typically say Yan is ahead on
time not against Magnus Carlson we see
Magnus with a 40 plus second lead this
is bad news for Yan in this game now
it's over 50 seconds and there's a pin
on B5 if you take on D5 twice you lose
your Rook because the bishop comes to C4
this starts to look bad for black as
white has the bishop hair in an open
space yeah this looks extremely this is
starting to look in Pleasant foron it's
really annoying for him that it's just
one move too late you would love to go
Bishop F7 here but again there takes and
Bishop to B5 so he goes Knight B8 not a
move you want make an B4 great move by
Magnus he's he is opening up the queen
side so that he can create an outside
Queen side passer that's such a great
move for Magnus and if he takes on A5
he's threaten to win a pawn or open the
B file for his Rook so Jan takes on B4
but we've talked about this in other
games the passer the outside pass Pawn
is the most dangerous one and there's a
bishop on F1 helping that pawn go all
the way up to A6 Benjamin I already have
the inkling to believe that Magnus Carl
is going to win this
game yeah this starting to look really
good for Magnus Jon can perhaps consider
the take on D5 followed by Bishop F7 and
I don't see right away how you actually
defend the pawn but Magnus is always
going to have good chances in the end
game with the Aon pushing on the board
but Robert look at the clock Yan all of
a sudden down to 30 seconds and he walks
into a pin but after Rook D7 Rook D7
Bishop to B5 there's Rook D6 and it's
thanks to the pawn on B4 so that pawn
would like to be thrown off the board
for just a second unfortun for Magnus it
is there now great awareness what has
changed by pushing a pawn it's blocked
the bishop on
A3 exactly and also with this recapture
white is weaken the D4 Square which is
what Yan is aiming for if the Knight
lands on D4 all of a sudden there's all
sorts of forks there's Knight of3 check
there's Knight C2 so Magnus has to be
careful here so let's see what he's
going to do I think taking on D7 makes a
lot of sense Bishop B5 black has to play
Rook D6 but what is the followup there
is Rook C1 but I suppose after Knight D4
black should be doing okay you can take
the pawn on C7 black can take and follow
up with let's say Bishop B8 and you can
defend the pawn on B5 so he starts with
Rook C1 if they Knight D4 there might be
Rook takes C7 watch out for tactics here
as The Rook on D7 is kind of pinned with
the Rook he walks into it but what is
this all right Magnus goes for he up
Pawn Rook now is forced king of seven
the only move perhaps Jon still has
quite good compensation here with the
Rook coming to uh well not see
one uh well where's The Rook going then
actually probably to C3 because you're
you're going to go Rook C3 and the
bishop slides back to B2 you throw in
Knight F3 check then bring Rook to oh
Rook B3 hangs Bishop C4 check idea this
is very complicated many tactics easy to
overlook some checks and forks and
everything pretty
much right but Rob maybe his ideas to go
Rook C3 attack the bishop in case Bishop
B2 then Knight F3 and then Rook C2 and
you keep chasing down the bishop if it
goes to A3 then you go Rook C3 attack it
again if it goes to A1 you go Rook C1
and maybe that way y would be able to
save a draw oh very important move
Bishop to F3 because G4 was not in time
to shut that Bishop out he goes Bishop
B2 going after this Knight I don't think
that Yan can afford to give the Knight
on D4 but you can't get Rook C1 in
without that Bishop leaving the board so
it's one of those
trade-offs yeah he goes knight2 okay now
Magnus perhaps has to trade off that
Knight for his Bishop it would weaken
the light squar around his King but if
he goes King H2 and and there we see the
trade if yo gets the time to go like
Rook C2 follow up Bishop F3 he should
have real counterplay but one thing you
have to be careful of Robert is that
after Bishop F3 if white plays F5 all of
a sudden white would be threatening
Checkmate on f8 oh this is Checkmate net
F5 Rook f8 Checkmate that's why Rook
takes G3 was not played but wait he
walks into
F5 F5 okay I guess you have to go G6 or
G5 isn't there even Bishop takes E5 in a
position like this the bishop on D1 is
hanging at the end of the line The Rook
on d8 Snipes it from across the
board right but black gets a lot of Pawn
you can recapture take on G3 maybe go
Rook A3 after Magnus down to 14 seconds
maybe he can also go A5 takes on B6 he
goes G4 okay but now you're going to
take the pawn yeah the A4 Pawn is loose
he wanted some kind of checkmating neck
that doesn't seem to fully exist and now
that A4 is gone B5 next I think Jan is
out of the woods exactly and with both
players getting low on time this is
anyone's game Rook B7 a cleverer a
little check by Magnus the bishop moves
the E2 Bishop E7 if anything it still
looks a little bit uncomfortable for y
here and Yan can blunder a bishop if the
king gets out to F2 now Rook oh the
rook's on B6 not on B7 King F2 there
there goes the backup he walked into it
in a different way and the pawn on F5
lives on because of Rook G5 this is
going to be a win for Magnus Carlson oh
no this looks like game one in
reverse and Bishop h8 what a great move
hanging on to the bishop okay king of
eight and now you just go Rook A7
followed by F6 wait but you are a little
bit stuck though how exactly do you make
progress rookie s maybe young can push
up the pawn the bishop is stuck over
here but now Magnus is pushing up his
King and this should be a win yeah it
should be the king can also help out F7
f8 and that is the game Magnus Carlson
goes up by three points he has now won
four straight games Benjamin that's very
very bad news for Yan
Nishi that's bad news for Yan indeed
he's having his chances in these games
but he feels to capitalize on them and
Magnus is just a little bit more precise
in those final moments and that is why
now he's having a three-point lead in
the match and we see that yand pomi he
essays the Italian Game No More Kings
Gambit from him but he needs to score
Victory from what is typically seen as
quite a solid position rather than a
tactical
one exactly yeah now I think the king's
gamit clearly backfired yon is playing
an opening right now that is objectively
sound he goes 93 this is quite
reminiscent of their last game in the
2021 World Chess Championship Magnus
going Rook to E8 I guess he wants to go
Bishop E6 trade with the Bishops again
not the most exciting game so far but
this is often how the Italian goes like
both players are trying to play for
small advantages and you see these
players know it very well because the
bishop Tri is offered white brings the
bishop to B5 black quickly Retreats the
bishop to D7 despite having just moved
the piece so look at this no pawns have
been traded it's an even position in
terms of material but where do they go
for from here white might strike with D4
but black is aiming E4
Pawn exactly yeah Magnus now rerouted
his Knight as C to G6 this gives him the
opportunity to go C6 kick the bishop
away and then perhaps go D5 at some
point in the future and build in the
center G3 an interesting move by Yan it
deprives the KN on G6 of the F4 square
but he is weakening some light squares
around his King the light squares could
be blacks for the taking especially if
you could hop your knight forward but
unfortunately the pawn on G3 takes away
the Knight on G6 is forward jumps and
Benjamin m coach always need to tell me
Knights on B3 G3 B6 and G6 they're often
the worst squares for Knight because not
only do they not get able to jump
forward based on a pawn but they end up
staying there a bit too
long exactly yeah so we'll see how this
plays out in the meantime Yan goes Pawn
to B4 expanding on the queen side the
good thing though about this n on G6 is
that it will always protect this Pawn on
D5 and that is why wait but Bish takes
D5 Robert isn't that just a blunder uh
oh the queen on C7 is loose so what is
Magnus thinking here oh Bishop B3
trusted him joh misses it oh let's let's
go back let's bring up an analysis Bo
just to show everybody what that looked
like when two of the best players on the
planet they just didn't really think
they didn't spend enough time Bishop
takes D5 you couldn't take back as
you're showing cuz the queen was loose
on C7 so black is lucky that you don't
actually lose you know a bunch of
material but that was a Central Pawn and
that would have been good news for Yan
pishi exactly and again he has to take
advantage of these opportunities when
they present them now Magnus is has a
very comfortable position he goes Queen
E6 taking the pawn Rook A1 and Bishop to
E6 and Robert I already slightly prefer
Black's position he's got a very nice
Center here the pawn on B4 is a little
bit loose the pawn on A4 was a littleit
loose that's why Yan moves it up to A5
and Magnus has very easy piece play and
the one thing going for Yan is the B4
Pawn cannot be captured just yet because
Bishop takes D5 the Queen would be in
line with the Rook Rooks win showdowns
with Queens but that was a big Miss I
think that's one of those moments where
we can't beat around the bush we can't
sugarcoat it Yan needs to find those
moves when when Magnus blunders and
maybe because it wasn't a huge change in
evaluation chess.com doesn't give it a
blunder that's what we call blunders
right top Grand Master say I just
blundered that idea he just didn't see
it coming and Yan unfortunately he
didn't see it
either yeah quite quite shocking cuz it
seemed to be quite element
but okay the good thing fori is that the
position is still even that being said
it's difficult for both sides to come
with a plan here so let's see what he's
going to do maybe like King G2 move his
King up a little bit like you said
earlier this spawn on B4 for the moment
is not hang because if you take there's
always going to be Bish takes the B D5
so we see Knight F5 by Yan the idea is
that in case black takes you recapture
with the pawn attack the Knight on G6
and once the Knight moves then this Pawn
on E5 is hanging so let's see what Magus
is going to do maybe just Queen D7
threaten to take the Knight and I don't
see anything better than just moving the
Knight back to E3 that's probably what
he's going to go for because there isn't
anything better there and that would be
a funny repetition of Queen D7 Knight E3
Queen D6 Knight F5 not one you see every
day but why should Magnus make a draw
here his Center is perfect look how
solid it is from B7 to D5 his E5 Pawn is
defended so if I'm Magnus I'm looking
for more I'm not just trying to draw
this game from the black side and he can
really put the pressure on Yan three
points is a lot but in bullet anything
can happen if he extends this to four
and Jan can tilt that would mean it's
magnus's match and Jan I don't know how
he would be able to get back in
it yeah it's looking tough already for
Yan he's going up on time here in this
one though he's already up a minute man
just has to move the Queen the queen can
really go anywhere can go to D7 C7 or
even f8 I wonder if after Queen D7 yon
perhaps is considering a move like
Knight to H4 to keep the game going
perhaps that could be worth
consideration yeah it also loosens up
the E5 Pawn because the Knight on G6 is
defending that pawn it's its only
Defender if the queen is to slide away
so I like the look of a knight H4 and
Magnus he's really spending a ton of
time here uh does he have any other
Square we talk about Queen D7 maybe he's
looking in a different
direction yeah Manna is spending a lot
of time here he's dropping 90 seconds
Below on the clock I don't know okay he
goes for it he goes for Bish takes a
five for but isn't this just losing a
pawn does he want after Rook takes E5
maybe Knight G4 and then after the Rook
moves back the Knight takes on F5 it
looks like that's what he's going
for right he goes Knight D7 same idea
perhaps yon could even consider a move
like D5 seconding The Rook but if you
take you get these two pawns over here
and if the queen moves maybe a move like
F6 I mean it I don't know what to make
of this by uh by Magnus remember when
Yan didn't sack on G5 in a previous game
Knight takes G5 he had an option to get
two pawns and open to King here he goes
go for it he's leaning back he plays D4
earns the two exclamation points and
this is what he needs to get him back in
the match moves like that you sacrifice
material in center of the board and
Benjamin as you said if Knight E5 D5 and
you allow Pawn to get up to F6
objectively we see the Evo bar saying
black is okay but in Blitz chest black
loses that position most of the time
yeah it looks super tough for black okay
here we see Magnus accepting the
sacrifice his Queen is under attack I
guess it's going to go to D7 hitting the
pawn you can also just defend the pawn
with a move like Knight D4 followed by
Rook E1 maybe F6 E6 at the right moment
or you can set up this battery Queen D3
Bishop C2 and then E6 or F6 and Magnus
in the meantime doesn't have any active
plan so I love this exchange sacrifice
byon it's great Queen takes B4 is
available uh if he does go for it just
now but I think F6 still looks very
strong and the point is that Knight G6
is unavailable in that particular line
because of Bishop takes D5 with a threat
not just against the queen but if Queen
takes G6 check the F Pawn would be
pinned so F6 here looks like a huge
opportunity for Yan but maybe Magnus is
willing to sacrifice his Queen and he'll
get two Rooks for it and there we go F6
is on the board great move by Yan like I
said in Caso takes takes a knight G6
there's Bishop takes D5 the queen is
under attack and you also threaten to
hit this Knight over here so perhaps
Magnus has to give up his Queen on B1
and he will have two Rooks though but
his King on G8 is going to be super weak
and the fact that Magnus hasn't moved
yet could he somehow missed this like
Queen takes B1 is the only move you lose
the game because Queen takes G6 check
leads to immediate mate he has to play
Queen takes B1 followed It Up by taking
on D5 I think with the Rook maybe he's
not even that much worse the Evo bar is
pretty high Benjamin but I think they're
great drawing chances for
black I mean to be fair this does look
really nice for right if you get the
queen to H6 is just going to be
Checkmate so you can even and there we
see Queen to C1 right away I guess
Magnus has to play King H7 or Rook D6 or
Rook A6 so that in case you take on
black still has the move Rook takes F6
we see King H7 Knight D4 this should be
a win for Yan I mean Knight F5 and queen
takes H6 is coming and Yan knows it the
way he just looked he's like yep that
Knight is coming in to help do some of
the heavy lifting and it's Unstoppable
don't play Knight F5 now because Knight
F3 check will win the the queen so he
breaks King up to G2 and Knight F5 is
next but now Magnus has the time to go
Rook D6 cuz now he's just in time with
Rook takes F6 Queen F4 nice move by Yan
Rook to E8 but black king is so weak
over here and I love this move H4 so
that in case of a potential Knight G6
you can always push the pawn all the way
up to H5 really nicely done from Yan
right now and now Queen F5 check you can
pick up the D5 Pawn if you want that as
well the Knight is loose on C4 the B7 F7
pawns are also hanging if Yan doesn't
win this game I I just don't know how
you beat Magnus
Carlson no he has to win this one he's
up two minutes on the clock Queen D7 ni
nice move by Yana now Queen E7 the point
is that after King G8 there is Knight to
F5 and there's just no move for Magnus
Jana is going to win this game this is
beautiful technique from Yan because he
could have taken the D5 Pawn but that
would have given black better chances
instead he just brings all of his pieces
the H Pawn the night and that's game
over yanomi strikes it's back to a
two-point lead for Magnus Carlson and
Jan he should be feeling much better
about his
chances yeah great game by and what I
especially liked from him is that when
he got into a winning position he took
his time he took his time to find the
precise moves and he put Magnus away we
saw that earlier in the match he got
some good positions but he rushed a
little bit and that's where he leted
Magnus Magnus escape and even turn the
game around but we see that if he takes
his time he's able to to be Magnus and
we also see that when Magnus loses a
game he goes back to a more solid
approach look at this Queens are off the
board it's not going to give Yan
tactical opportunities he firmly
believes that he can beat mag mag can
beat Yan in end games that may look
equal but have more to them than
initially meets the
eye exactly yeah so perhaps the move C3
here restricting the Knight on C6 it can
no longer go to B4 and you defend the
pawn on D4 once more Bishop G4 a nice
developing move by yon I assume he
should be doing fine here with a move
with a rook moving to8 but like you said
before Robert Magnus is playing for
these very small advantages his pieces
are slightly more flexible does n C8 n
on C6 sorry cannot go anywhere for the
moment rookie eight the N on2 for the
moment is under attack though and Magnus
was mad at himself I think the reason
why is when he played C3 after the
Knight went to C6 his Knight couldn't
jump to E5 which was one of his major
plans so Magnus seems like he's a bit
uncomfortable with what's been happening
and this position does look good for
white in the sense that there's no
immediate risk in the position the
Knight can't go to F5 now because the E2
Knight was loose he plays G4 gains more
space that Knight can go to G3 from E2
as well I can't say that I love White's
position but I think he a nice small
plus caroan
style exactly yeah he just has a little
bit more space for his pieces they they
can maneuver a little bit easier I guess
this KN wants to go to G2 maybe this
Knight wants to go to G3 King F2 Bishop
d2 move this Rook into the game then
slowly but surely expand on the king
side this looks like vintage Magnus so
let's see how he will try to tighten the
screws in this end game he brings up kn
back to G2 that allows him to play
Bishop F4 next if he wants to trade
those pieces he can also play H4 King F2
Rook H1 maybe strike and I think this is
a mistake that many players make is they
think oh just because the Queens are off
the board there's no no such thing as an
attack I think white can go after the
black king with those Pawn pushes up the
king
side exactly yeah what we have here is
called a queenless middle game only the
Queens have been traded but for the rest
all of the pieces are still on the board
King G7 by yon moving his up the board a
little bit perhaps this move Bishop that
you suggested earlier Robert it would
force the trade of Bishops black would
have to trade as otherwise White's going
to trade themselves and give you double
isolated pawns on D6 and then the Knight
will come to F4 and G5 all of a sudden
is a threat I love it and so Bishop F4
looks reasonable I might even start with
H4 just because I'm not sure really if
G5 is a threat from White's perspective
but it keeps that alive so it makes
black have to think but madus is the one
thinking here we're about even on the
clock I do prefer White's position but
you need to create specific
targets H4 also a nice move by Magnus we
see H5 byuk G5 now the Knight moves back
to G8 this might look passive but the
Knight can reroute from G8 to5 from
where where it would be putting pressure
on the pawn on H4 Magnus recaptures with
the Knight and actually I like this move
Knight C7 as now y can go Pawn of C6 to
strengthen that pawn on D5 extremely
precise play from Yan because the knight
at C6 was bad it left D5 vulnerable he
reroutes that knight from C6 to E7 to C8
up to D6 we can see more play for black
and look at C4 from Magnus he's striking
in the center while black is moving to
the back rank I feel like there are some
attacking chances against the black king
especially if a knight lands on
E5 for sure yeah what I also like about
this move C4 and Knight to C4 is that it
stops black from playing Knight to D6 so
now you have to find a different way to
get your knight into the game Yan of
course could also play Knight G7
followed by Knight F5 but the moment you
go Knight F5 white can always take and
you definitely do not want to recapture
with the pawn so Yan should be doing
fine here but he still has to figure out
how exactly he's going to get his pieces
into the game and so for Magnus King F2
comes to mind Rook E2 followed by Rook
to E1 doubling on the E file he plays
Rook D1 instead maybe he's hinting at
some kind of D5 Pawn push at the right
moment and also well the Knight was
stuck on C8 for the time being but he's
trying to free both of his Knights so
that Knight on E7 can can move
successfully and then the Knight on C8
can join it
afterwards yeah exactly Rook the nice
move getting out of the pin on the eal
the bishop can go to F5 or to E8 to
strengthen that F7 point a little bit
Robert he might have to be careful
though Bishop E8 might run into some
like Bishop takes G6 and there are
tactics with Knight E6 check so let's
see what J is going to do here white
certainly has some attacking chances
here it's a good find the E6 Square is
soft so watch out for those sacrifices
on G6 and here maybe Yan just take my
Bishop that's not important you have an
isolated Pawn so I could see an argument
for Knight B6 please please take that
Bishop I'll blockade the square in front
of your iqp he goes Knight D6 instead
because Knight E7 is actually covering
the square but this transition Knight D7
Rook D7 into the more of an end game
that does seem good for
black yeah I like how jannis played this
he's actually out maneuvered Magnus
perhaps a little bit one of his nights
is headed to F5 it would pressure the
pawn on H4 and the pawn on D4 the Knight
on E7 is loose but there's not a single
Discovery for Magnus that works here if
you take on G6 black recaptures with the
Knight problem solved if you take on F7
you recapture with the king and the
Knight is defend and if you take on D7
you recapture with the rook and the
Knight is defended again so he goes King
to F2 I think it's a good move bring
your King as a weapon in the end game
but I like Bishop F5 here you mentioned
that black needs the F5 Square for a
knight let's first swap Bishops open the
dile for the Rook on d8 then plant a
knight on an outpost square that H4 pawn
and both the D4 Pawn they're very loose
and black staring at
them yeah black would love to trade of
these Bishops also because all of these
pawns are on light Square so I think
Magnus should keep those on the board
with Bishop to F1 also because it stops
black from putting a knight on a five
Bishop F1 seems to be the correct choice
at this moment for Magnus Carlson I'm
looking the clocks Magnus he is up just
10 seconds so it's pretty even on the
clock and Yan continuing to make good
moves let's get Rook to see it maybe
we'll have a C5 in the near future or
even a knight B5 don't count that out
because if white takes on B5 and C takes
B5 there's an open C file and only black
has a rook down that
line exactly so now we have an
interesting position both sides have
gotten all of their pieces into the game
and now the question is how do you
further improve it's not obvious to me
at all I think if black gets a move or
two maybe he wants to go Rook C7 defend
the Knight on E s a little bit more
maybe bishop to C8 and then move a
knight to F5 to hit this Pawn on H4 or
actually maybe the D Knight as then you
also put maximum pressure on that pawn
on
D4 oo Knight C4 so Magnus trying to
trade off pieces and if you play D5 is
white I'm wondering if black will play
C5 push through and try to give chances
for a pass Pawn on the queen side so
it's a big moment here for Magnus that
isolated Pawn is a long-term weakness
but maybe you can't successfully push it
and if that's the case then you're going
to have to make a move like I don't know
Knight back to E5 or Knight to E3 just
trying to create some sort of play for
yourself but Robert does this actually
work can yon just take on D5 maybe take
on C4 take on D5 and then create a pin
along the defa it all looks very loose
and also like you mentioned before there
is that Rook C2 check so quite a risky
approach here by Magnus I think he's
going to give up that pawn in the center
so Knight C4 Bishop C4 Pawn takes D5 may
just Bishop back to B3 three it does
look bad for white now that I actually
I'm seeing it happen on the board and
Yan he senses that he has an opportunity
he is now up a pawn and
better wait but Bishop takes D5 here's
the thing Robert if you go Rook D7
there's Bishop B3 but does he have
Bishop to C2 Al there's Rook D2 and then
your Bishop is hanging so what is the
move here for Yan he goes Rook C2 check
but now King King G3
maybe oh he has Rook E2 because Rook
takes E2 the king can take back
protecting The Rook on D1 so what was
the Miss there from Yan it was not easy
to
spot no for sure it was not so let's see
what he's going to do here perhaps he's
going to trade the king will recapture
he can take on D5 black should be doing
absolutely fine here but keep in mind
he's down in the match so he would like
to take advantage of any opportunity he
can get so can he perhaps cook up
something here it is officially the
final game in the 5 plus one and we see
pieces are being traded off Yan realizes
that you he should be able to hold the
draw here but I prefer the Knight to the
bishop because in this end game the
Knight get hop from color complex the
color complex the bishop is stuck in the
light squares not attacking anything of
course it should be a draw but much of
Chess should be a draw without someone
making a mistake and mistakes happen
especially when the players are down to
a minute
each exactly and keep in mind that this
spawn on H4 can turn into a weakness if
black can go King E6 to F5 black can
also play for win so it's not that easy
here for Magnus as well also the
position is fairly open and that often
favors the bishop so let's see what
Magnus will do he goes ight E4 now yon
has to trade as the paent F6 is under
attack and then perhaps he has the time
to step step up his King and King E6
there might be Knight C5 check so that
could work out for black but you need to
be careful so he plays B6 first of
course and yeah there doesn't seem to be
any more forward jumps King E6 coming
benj you make a good point the black
could actually win this game if White's
not careful and that King goes up to F5
and into
G4 exactly so King F4 by Magnus now King
E6 the black king can move up to well it
could not have moved up to D5 because of
Knight F6 but her re see Bop C6 and
Knight C3 for the moment Magnus is
stoping that King from Robert I think
this is a missed opportunity for Yan I
think objectively this is probably a
draw but what does why do here if you
move the king back there's King F5 you
cannot move the Knight there's King D5
so Magnus actually has to play quite
accurately here to hold the draw I think
and you see Magnus and Yan I think
they're reviewing the game both them
looking oh there were some chances here
or there I'm with you that Magnus would
have been the player who had to prove
that he could make a draw there but the
draw was agreed probably Yan wanted to
get through with that time control
they're moving to quicker time controls
here at the speed chest Championship
presented by coinbase but Magnus Carlson
he has a two-point lead over yand pomi
and Yan we just saw him leave his chair
he does not look particularly
happy yeah perhaps he HD the you know
when the game ends you see the valuation
pop up and he saw that he has an
advantage there and against Magnus again
you have to take any opportunity you can
get and I think with colors reverse
Magnus would have played on there but it
is a 5 and half 3 and half lead for the
world's number one player Magnus Carlson
5 and a half three and a half Benjamin
that's a very successful first time
patol for the
Norwegian I think he cannot be unhappy
at all he started down a point in the
match also then in game four so yon was
actually winning with white pieces and
Magnus completely turned the one around
and it has taken a two-point lead so uh
yeah I think Magnus can be quite
satisfied he's definitely satisfied he's
going to go into the three plus one with
the lead so he's thrilled and I can't
think of anything or anyone much smarter
or faster than Magnus Carlson but if you
wish your financial systems were as fast
and smart as a 2023 speed chest
Championship presented by coinbase they
can be check out coin coinbase.com
updatethe system or use the command
coinbase in chat to learn more we're
going to head into the 3+1 but now we
take a break for more from the speeds
Championship presented by coinbase
Magnus Carlson versus yand pomi just in
a
[Music]
few
[Applause]
a
[Music]
n
white to
move
H you got to take H1 daily for every
daily puzzle
[Music]
got it Bishop G7 King G7 Queen E5 Queen
E4 in the end white wins a
piece nailed
it everyone loves playing chess and
everyone loves chess club but there's
also a time and a place for playing all
your favorite games hey we're trying to
have a lesson here you need to get out
of here recently more kids have been
playing chess than ever in school but
sadly we've learned that they may not
always be playing chess at the most
appropriate time he class while it might
be sometimes okay to grab a game between
classes or if your teacher gives you
permission and hasn't given you an
assignment it's not okay to be playing
chess in school when you aren't supposed
to and chess should never come between
you taking your studies seriously and
Cooper operating with your fellow
students and
teachers chess over the board or on the
phone is a great way to spend time with
friends but let's make sure that this
school year we don't let too much chess
happen in the classroom focus on your
school cuz chess.com will always be
there when class is over chess is school
your all right that was awesome
everybody great job look what I did
Danny did you spell that yeah can we get
some other letters please what's wrong
with
it
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the 2023 speed
Championship presented by coinbase Yan
is no stranger to the speed CH
Championship he's no stranger to Magnus
Carlson these two played the 2021 world
championship match against one another
of course Magus Carlson retained his
crown he defeated yand pomi with games
to spare but Benjamin it's 2023 now
these are two different versions of
their previous selves Magnus Carlson
with a two-point lead but what do you
make of this match and what do you think
Yan has to do to strike
back I think y overall has been playing
good chest so far however he has lost a
few games games due to some unfortunate
blunders and sometimes we see him
playing a little bit too quickly however
he did close down the margin a little
bit in that game with the with the
Italian so he just needs to keep playing
his his chess and try to avoid avoid
blunders he has been His Own Worst Enemy
at times throughout his career but
Magnus Carlson is the enemy of most when
we're talking about facing someone
across the chessboard Magnus with a
two-point lead we're getting into the 3
minute plus 1 second increment time
control and well mag is hard to beat
with unlimited time in the clock but
when we get to those final seconds
unlike some other super Gams he's also
really good at bullet
scrambles exactly yeah and also I would
like to one add one thing Jon really has
to take advantage of every opportunity
he can get in that last game we see he
still had some some chances but he just
took a draw which was a little bit
surprising to me and if Magnus you know
had that position from the black side
perhaps he would have played on but that
is a thing of the past just like their
20 21 world championship match and we're
o look at this this is a fun opening and
if you blink you would have missed it
but there was a temporary Knight
sacrifice that black could not
take let's show everybody real quick Yan
played this move Knight E6 she cannot
take the Knight as there will be
Checkmate on H5 so Magnus just played
the move Queen to B6 and now we have
this position white is the bishop pair
but black has pretty easy
development yes look at the pieces
they're out it looks very bizarre
because black is missing a dark Square
bishop and you castled with pawns at E7
and G7 this may be like the only opening
that you could possibly do this in yeah
it's quite funny because white got rid
of the bishop the Knight recaptured on
D7 and then moved out to G6 indeed like
I said usually have to play E6 or G6 to
get castled so um yeah but overall Yan
has the bishop air Magnus has a lead in
development for now so let's see what he
will do I think if yon gets the
opportunity to to consolidate here with
moves like Bishop E3 and queen C3 he
might get the
advantage and for a second I forgot that
Yan was playing with the white pieces
because I saw a pair of Bishops I saw a
player trying to squeeze out an
advantage but Yan he is universal I know
we've been talking about him with the
tactics he's somebody who is a great
endgame player you have to be great at
all facets of the game usually people
have preferences but Jan saying let's
play solid chess let me use the two
Bishops to my advantage and why not this
does look like a nice position for white
exactly but look at what Magnus is doing
he goes Bishop to G4 trade off his
Bishop to go Knight H4 put pressure on
this bishop and if you go Bishop to E2
then he goes Knight F5 putting pressure
on the pawn on D4 and the bishop on E3
so Magna is doing a great job
neutralizing White's Bishop air I can't
get over the E7 and G7 pawns like it
doesn't look like I'm watching a
standard game of chess it looks like
fish are random and yet this is where we
are and it does look Pleasant for black
as you said the Knight comes back to F5
hitting the bishop on E3 there no D5
tactics because the piece attacking the
queen will be removed from the board so
Benjamin this looks like you know
balanced position do you prefer the
Bishops or the knights at this
stage it's a good question Robert I
think now y's going to recapture with
the pawn I think I would slightly prefer
Black's position it feels like he's got
the easier moves here maybe even a move
like Pawn E5 putting a lot of pressure
on that pawn on D4 and there we have it
on the board yon takes it right away but
Knight E4 taking the queen and where do
you go he has go back to C1 you can't go
up the E3 Pawn that would be game over
so Yan looked a bit surprised but Knight
E4 was the natural jump against the
queen yeah this looks bad for white yeah
this doesn't look good Rook take C5 and
you're just stuck with his isolated Pawn
on E3 your Bishop on E2 is not doing a
whole lot and Robert we've talked about
this before the Yon just rushed there
again with a move Pawn takes E5 he
didn't spend much time that's clear but
he is up over now 40 seconds on the
clock so Benjamin this is a quicker time
control we have to take that into
consideration maybe some of his game
plan is let me push Magnus towards the
brink of a loss on
time exactly Queen H5 Bishop F3 okay now
Magnus can just recapture the queen and
he some full control maybe Yan should
have gone for something more active like
Bishop to H5 but yeah now it's all
Magnus he has white has this isolated
Pawn on E3 he's got the active Queen on
E5 the active Knight on e4 we see Yan
trading but this is just very passive
defense yeah it looks like it should be
sturdy enough even though black is
better I love cinear moves like that
Rook D3 going right after the E3 pawn
and if white takes the queen infiltrates
via D3 and white is stuck in the mud I
love that move Rook D3 and I like that
Magnus made it very
quickly yeah we see training on on D3
queen of one nice move by Yan if you
trade the Queens you uh you're your king
can go to E2 and if you take on E3 then
white takes the queen D3 and wins a rook
so Yan or Magnus has to move his Queen
if he wants to keep the advantage he
moves back he does have a slight Edge
because of the pawn structure black with
two Pawn isons white with three namely
the isolated Pawn on E3 and I think
Queen D7 was good Rook d8 to follow but
how do you actually crash through if you
are Magnus Rook G3 is he going for like
an attack with Queen
F6 I think so but Magnus can just
eliminate any counterplay with the move
Queen to D1 you trade of the queens and
black is very quick to go Rook to D2
afterwards and it's very difficult to
see how White's keeping their Queen side
together he goes Queen D6 instead
attacking The Rook maybe now just King
H2 he goes Queen F3 okay and queen E5
great centralization for Magnus he
covers the only weak point the G7 Pawn
in the position everything is defended
and now a rook can slap to D2 but that's
a nice move by Jan because his Rook on
G3 protects B3 if there's a swap of
queens and
F4 exactly and also now his Rook can
come back into the game with rookie
three the oppent A2 is on attack but
just go a four and like you said Robert
Theon B3 is weak but right now it is
defendant and rookie 3 a nice move
stopping the king from marching up the
board this should be a draw but it is
still a little bit uncomfortable for
white yes because black can play G6 King
G7 King F6 and the white king is cut off
so he tries to bring his King up via G3
and F3 I think that's smart but look at
Magnus he says please take my Pawn H4
I'll take on G2 your king is running out
of real
estate right that's why Yan goes K three
but A5 Magnus slowly but surely
tightening the screws young can of
course always go rookie to I think
Magnus is going to keep his Rook on the
board with like Rook to D1 and maybe
then a move like King G4 can be
considered but Magna is definitely the
one playing for a win here Rook e 2 is a
big decision because if you trade on E2
the black king goes King E7 King D6 King
C5 King B4 I feel like black does have
some very good winning chances but it
becomes a race because the H4 Pawn was
also weak so instead Yan just plays G3 I
think that was the correct decision
ision considering the time situation and
I have to add Benjamin that Yan offered
a draw at some point and once again
Magnus played
on yeah it feels like Magnus has a
slight edge here the king is now moving
up to F6 May to F5 the pawn in the four
is a little bit weak so Magus definitely
still has chances here he just goes B6
slowly but surely improving his position
Jan's got the open E fall for his Rook
but it cannot go well maybe this could
be a way to create some counterplay
quickly and make a draw
so he was Rook B7 if Rook B3 he wants C5
but then black has B5 this is not
simple right so takes takes C6 B4 though
like how exactly do you make the draw
probably go to the a pawn here like Rook
to A7 and Rook C3 we're going to see a
pawn up end game for
black right so now in case of A4 there
C7 okay goes F5 check I guess you go
King to H4 to defend everything and
after Rook C3 you can it goes King G5
also fine now black probably goes Rook
G3 check as otherwise there will be a
check on
B7 that was a really essential check on
B7 and we see this liquidation and I
guess this is what Yan is relying on
he's going to get the B Pawn for the C
Pawn but is there some kind of Checkmate
being set up no the king just runs back
to G3 and this should be equal but black
is
better black is certainly better but
white just sits and there's no way to
make progress so Magnus here just forces
the draw and there we have it okay so
they played to the the bear kings that
was a good hold from yand pomi but a
good result for Magnus he leads in the
match he burnt a bunch of the clock off
the match timer but a a nice start I
think for all the fans in game one of
the 3 plus one and by the way if you're
new to this Channel right now throw a
sub in it's September but also keep
following the speed Chess Championship
presented by coinbase because this is
another quarterfinal match and after
this one ends we do have NBL versus
nihal sain so you will not want to miss
all of the action here but back to this
board Benjamin we see that we had an
alipin Sicilian Magnus going back to one
of my childhood favorite
openings yeah we see Magnus here with
the Pawns in the middle he has active
development maybe The Rook can move to
D1 he's spending a little bit of time
though Yan's still playing quickly there
we have the move for Rook D1 so let's
see now how Yan is going to play like
maybe bishop D7 but it all looks a
little bit clumsy so I think Magnus can
be quite satisfied about the outcome of
the opening here we see Mo B to D7 what
white can often do here is combine moves
like Bishop to D3 and queen E4 to try to
start some sort of attack on the king
side and he goes Knight C3 so we are
going to see a transformation of Pawn
structure but I like what you're
pointing out that the bishop on D3 will
stare at the black king and if you play
G6 to blunt that Bishop you give up the
H6 Square for the second white Bishop
this is starting to look like the
makings of an attack but Benjamin we
know if there is no attack black is
better because of the C3 and A2 isolated
Pawns
exactly all of these pawns can be a
little bit weak the pawn on A2 the pawn
on C3 also the pawn on E5 nice move here
by Magnus going H4 because eventually
you want to go Queen E4 black has to go
G6 and then you can follow up quickly
with the move H5 so he can also play H5
here right away anticipating that move
G6 and look at the clocks Magnus he's
down nearly 40 seconds Yan is playing
this quickly where's the Checkmate says
Yan you're attacking with your queen and
your Bishop I've stopped that diagonal
if he doesn't take with the H Pawn I'll
be very surprised but Yan is thinking
so can you even take with the F
Pawn I'd be shocked because the if you
play FX G6 you critically weaken the
pawn on E6 but he goes for it wow Robert
this looks like a serious mistake I'm
wondering why he went for this like what
he was worried about on the H file maybe
he thought that white would quickly get
some pieces over there and he's trying
to bring his Rook towards the black king
but this bishop on F7 is a big
Pawn
yeah Rook A5 this looks very awkward for
monan Bish to B3 now magnes will always
have pressure on the pawn on E6 he can
maybe move a knight at G5 at some point
this looks terrible for black really
terrible and the C3 Pawn is now targeted
it is a weakness but I think that white
can go with a rook lift Rook E3 both
defending the C3 pawn and when you move
your knight out the way I feel like The
Rook would have been able to jump
towards the king side but he goes Rook
D1 and it got a question mark still
looks good for white
though right so what happens if Yan
takes on D1 how are you going to
recapture you can take with the Rook but
then you hang the pawn on E5 you can
also take with the bishop but you would
like to keep that Bishop in active
position but what is this move A5 by Yan
I don't I don't see the point because A4
is not even a
threat so this question should be asked
again Rook takes D1 Rook takes D1 Knight
takes E5 perhaps Magnus would just take
back and plant a rook on D7 at the end
of the line and say that he's got good
control but that doesn't look very
simple I think that black would have
chances there but but Benjamin the bar
is all the way up in magnus's favor yeah
this looks great for Magnus and takes in
case Rook takes D1 you can also take
with the bishop take with the Rook Jan
goes Bishop to f8 but this will always
leave him with very weak dark squares
Magnus traits on d8 and I mean maybe
like Knight G5 now oh that's a Crusher
because now F7 is hanging directly you
can't take this bishop that looks free
on H6 cuz Queen takes F7 Queen takes H7
is a direct Checkmate and if you play
move like Queen E7 to save your Bishop
Bishop takes f8 that's going to hurt oh
goodness you just have no space for your
pieces and E6 is loose Robert I think
this one is just over if you go Queen E7
Magnus just takes and after Queen takes
Bishop takes E6 you cannot take it
there's Queen f8 and knight6 and here
same thing Bishop F7 knight6 and the
game is over it's completely done in
extra exchange for Magnus he looks bored
with this one and Yan has had enough
Magnus wins he is now up by three points
once once more Benjamin those are the
type of games we were talking about Yan
cannot afford those little slips that
turns the position from okay to really
bad yeah I am shocked that he did not
recapture with the HP I understand that
he was worried about getting checkmated
along the H foul but taking with the F
Pawn always leaves him with a weak Pawn
on D6 and Magnus took full advantage of
that bad news for Yan pomi fans out
there and if you were a fan of his in
the 2021 world championship match
against Magnus you'll recognize the
opening here it's a Spanish white can
take on B5 now and open up the a file
for his Rook go Knight C3 Knight D5
Benjamin I feel like we've been seeing a
lot of this in the speeches Championship
oh and then mous slid by mag Don had
Knight C3 pre moved oh my goodness and I
wonder what's going to happen here
because Magnus he's probably too much of
a competitor to even ask for a draw but
sometimes when people Mouse it right
they a draw is offer just to get to the
next game but I think Magnus he doesn't
even want one he's so disgusted with
himself I think we should go back show
an instant replay of what happened there
because suddenly Magnus is down two
pawns and might just lose this but if we
can go back in time Benjamin I think
it's important to show everybody where
that Mouse slip
happened yeah so here yon took on B5 and
instead of recapturing Magnus Mouse SLI
of course he wanted to play ponx B5 but
he played the move A5 but lucky for him
Jon had Knight C3 pre moved otherwise of
course he would have taken the Knight on
six so Knight C3 Jon still has a great
position as now he's up two pawns but
there's still work to be done and maybe
at the back of his mind yon could be
thinking like hey I could have already
won this game I could have taken a
knight but I feel like if you win like
that it feels even worse but now it
seems like a more legitimate fight even
though we'll always have an asterisk
because of a mouse slip so the Knight
comes back to D7 it's going to slip
around to the B6 Square Hit The Rook hit
the bishop I don't feel like this is as
easy as one would think no sure there's
still work to be done for for Jan he's
obviously got a great position up two
puns I mean really a dream come true in
the realz I like what he's doing though
with this move Knight A4 he wants to go
C3 afterwards and trap this Knight on
B4 okay so Magnus you know he looks like
he's reeling Yan is making it look easy
C3 is a great move next and if black has
to play D5 well now you definitely can't
play D5 to fre tonight C3 F takes E4 so
all Magnus is making this messy
right so let's see so C3 Pawn takes E4
you can go Knight D2 but then the Knight
can jump into D3 so Magna is doing a
great job complicating this game I don't
know it's not over yet this 84 is a
little bit off so let's see what y will
do here maybe he'll play C3 F takes E4
Knight takes E5 because you're going to
lose that F3 Knight anyway so you might
as well steal that Central Pawn not
allow a black pawn to take on your
knight on F3 and that seems to be the
simplest ah he goes even Knight back to
E1 all right this also still looks great
for young but now Magnus can go for like
Bishop F5 followed by Queen E8 the G6
and again he's still in this game he is
down two pawns but white has this
cluster of Pawns on the Queens side that
are that are difficult to set in motion
I like the plan for black that you just
mentioned the bishop F5 Queen E8 Queen
G6 all that stuff I think it's Black's
only chance considering you are down a
couple pawns and the Knight on A4 is
stuck over there and it will take a
while play B3 Knight B2 he goes so he
goes B4 he's even more direct I like it
but Bishop F5 Queen G6 to follow
Benjamin is the only chance that black
has with Bishop E4 and go for
checkmate and there he goes Queen E5 now
maybe just King to H7 and if you take on
C5 there might be Queen G6 Bishop takes
H3 as a threat but even more important
Bishop to E4 attacking the queen and the
pawn on G2 so this one is not over just
yet yet Robert unbelievable if Yan
doesn't win a game where Magnus Mouse
slipped on what move is that move like
10 and then doesn't win up a couple
pawns he will be beside himself you need
to win this game if you're Yap pami but
Magnus refuses to lose I actually think
this is a really difficult
position it's already really tricky I
mean again if you take on C5 there's
Queen
G6 I don't know it's yeah I'll be tilted
out of my mind if I would not win this
game if I was young maybe there's still
Queen F3 to meet Bish Bishop B4 with
Queen G3 let's see what he's going to go
for he takes
on oh is he going to go for it he's
going for it he has to at this point
there was a checkm on G2 threaten so
he's taking this bishop and the evalar
approves so yand pomi with great
awareness I think now he brings his
Knight to B6 he protects his C4 Pawn the
Knight can slide even to D5 oh wait yeah
he's just pushing the C PA he gives up
the E Pawn for the C Pawn what do you
make of
this yeah I love it for young Magnus
goes Rook D6 he go Rook G6 and Str
checkm over here so Rook A4 tacking the
queen nice little move I guess the queen
has to go to to like D3 to go after this
pawn it looks great for you Hest
everything is defendant he's got these
passers but still some work to be done
so can he play C6 and C7 that's my first
question I know the B5 Pawn is hanging
but that c Pawn gets up the board very
quickly another option is just to play
C4 yourself but that does keep your Rook
away from the King side like Rook to G6
does seem a little worrisome yeah now I
would be quite reluctant to go C C4 as
you said it allows Rook to G6 followed
by Queen E4 so Rook B4 I like this one
much better to Rook can always keep an
eye on the king side it does hang the
pawn of C3 but I think Robert he just
wants to go Rook F to B1 defend
everything and then go C6 at the right
moment how often do you see two minor
pieces and three pawns for a queen is a
material imbalance that I am not
accustom to but those pass pawns are not
just on the second rank they're
mobilized they're ready to become a
Queen and so I'm with you it looks very
very strong here for white he goes Rook
to B1 he just wants to keep everything
together he can play Rook to C1 Pawn to
C6 Pawn to C7 this looks very difficult
to deal with right Rook G6 a tricky
little move though by Magnus he still
wants to go for this IDE of Queen E3 and
queen E4 and Robert this one that's not
over yet if the queen lands on e4 it
will be uncomfortable to deal with the
Checkmate threat so I love to move Rook
B4 byon great decision making from Yan
pomi keeps taking away critical squares
from Black's pieces and c67 is not going
anywhere he is B5 protected he's got a
rook behind the pass C Pawn the Knight
is defended by the bishop on E3 this is
a good try for Magnus hitting both Rooks
but now the Rooks are coord C6 at long
last that has to be next on the
agenda exactly now C6 is definitely
threat followed by C7 magnus's clock is
taking he's down to 18 seconds Robert I
don't see how he's stopping y from
marching up the board here he's not the
pawn is going forward and I think the
Magnus he's pretty much resigned because
he feels like he has no way to defend
he's down to 5 Seconds needs to find a
move here is he just going to lose on
time C can you go Queen B3 though take
on B5 C7 and then give up this rook and
Yan one on time I I don't know Magnus I
think could have kept this game going a
little bit longer by taking here taking
the Knight and I guess well anyway we're
off to another game I I think he just
assumed that it was going to be a loss
no matter what and it's hard to even
play when you Mouse slip so now Magnus
has to avoid any kind of tilting he's up
two point so he's still doing well in
the match but it feels really bad to
play A5 instead of a Tak
B5 right but it was impressive that he
did find a way to keep the game going
Jon had to find that Queen sacrifice to
keep his Advantage but to his credit he
did and he never let his Advantage go no
he did not y pal sheet now within two
points s to five I I'm seeing another
alipin Sicilian I'm happy about it my
childhood feels like it was all worth it
just to see an alipin Sicilian and a
speed chest championship match between
these two but you look at this opening
white has an extra Pawn on the queen
side black has an extra Pawn in the
center and that's the dynamic that's
something that you need to watch out for
in an end game where white pushes up B4
and C5 but in the middle game the E6
Pawn that's a very useful Pawn to have
in the
center exactly so I like what he's doing
here with A3 and B4 expanding on the
queen side now the bishop has to move
back I suppose the E7 if you go to B6 it
can always be blocked with the move Pawn
of C5 he goes Bishop to D4 Robert I
think he's not unhappy about this trade
but what about Rook A2 you want to go
Rook D2 pin the bishop and this just
seems like a loss of time I don't like
the move at all it earned a question
mark which I think is deserved because
of Rook A2 Knight takes D4 Queen takes
D4 will trade the Queens off the board
and maybe Jan feels the endgame is
perfectly acceptable for him but Magnus
should slide The Rook up and over to the
center and it feels like there's a huge
problem with the pin down the defile
yeah so Magnus taking his time but I'm
sure Rook A2 is on his radar like I said
The Rook is moving over here I don't see
what black is going to do about it maybe
you just have to go Bishop to B6 but
then you've lost critical time yeah why
not have retreated immediately that's
the big question and Rook A2 is on the
board he plays E5 but this looks like
you're going to lose a pawn directly
instead of Rook D2 Knight F5 there's
Knight takes E5 for example I don't like
the look of this at all this looks
extremely loose for y the good thing for
him though is that he's up almost a
minute on the clock Rook D2 certainly
looks very logical here for Magnus
Knight F5 you just go Knight takes E5
the Knight cannot be taken as you hang
the queen so you're going to have to go
Queen C7 maybe white can then just take
on D4 can you actually sacrifice the
queen Yan just did it in the previous
game so I'm starting to wonder if Knight
F5 Knight E5 we get a rook and a knight
for a queen and a pawn but white does
have a lack of development and a bunch
of loose squares it's probably not
sufficient but maybe in a Blitz game it
can work out yes so we see Knight tak5
on the board I am I really am doubtful
that Bish Tak C5 is going to work out I
think you just have to keep pieces on
the board like Queen C7 or queen E7 it
does look really bad though as why can
just take on D4 if black cre captures
with a knight you can take the queen or
you can take the Knight and you will
have two minor pieces for the rook and
that is why yon takes on E5 but now he's
down a clean pawn and white has the
bishop hair the good news the only bit
of good news for black is that the C4
Pawn is a backwards pawn and white is is
behind in development and the clock
situation is no longer one where Yan is
well ahead so Magnus has great chances
over the board but maybe Yan is counting
on the fact that he has no more
weaknesses now that he's dropped the
pawn but Magnus plays this so precisely
he moved his Knight into the game with
Knight D2 to F3 kicking that Queen away
and Robert what about a move like Bishop
F4 here in case you take the bishop you
can take on d8 and if you take on D3 you
take the queen and I think all of it
works out brilliantly but he goes Queen
C2 I love Bishop F4 it was taking
advantage of tactic actually earned was
that a blunder symbol there for Queen to
C2 a knight D6 also in inaccuracy a Miss
by Yan so both players are on shaky
grounds but he's going after to C4
Bishop F5 is a secondary threat white
might have to play Move Like Rook oh
wait Rook D4 might hang the B5 Pawn as
you're pointing out so what does Magnus
do here I don't know it's a good
question a lot of threats here all of a
sudden from Yan we see mag is dropping
below minute this one is not over just
yet maybe Robert you can play C5 Al then
there's Bishop
F5 whoa because the C Pawn is pinned to
the queen down on C2 so Bishop F5 looks
like a good try and you can see Yan
thinking here he's like something feels
available to Black there's going to be a
tactic and he plays Bishop to
F5 and queen C8 by yon okay Rook C1 okay
so if you take the Rook I think white
just recaptures and you have to go back
to the passive d8 Square sry E8 Square
which looks terrible maybe maybe white
black can take here you can take on d8
black recaptures but then your queen is
hanging oo that's actually a really
important point and if you could steal
that pawn no longer does white have an
opposing passer up the queen side so a
lot of us will be temped to take on D3
go up in exchange and Yan goes for that
but you actually see the evaluation bar
go even higher for white because look at
how passive black is a knight E5 he
doesn't even take the pawn back he wants
take with a knight Hit The Rook on d8 97
check Fork Benjamin this is getting out
of hand for y pomi this is looking ugly
he's up the exchange but all of his
pieces are are are passive only does n
on F6 is not on the back rank like you
said Magnus wants to take here attack
The Rook also threaten a fork over here
so maybe Yan has to move the queen
preemptively but I I don't know I mean
it looks very bad also Magnus has this
majority on the queen side this looks
great looks like a tough position for
Yan who won the previous game he brings
his Knight up to D5 and now Knight C6
because Knight F4 is by Knight E7 check
winning that
Queen and also Robert V can pick up this
Pawn on H7 although not anymore the
bishop on F4 is under attack so I assume
at some moment you move it maybe to G3
and again it's super difficult for black
to to make an active move here but
there's some tricks because Knight takes
d8 my backfire Queen takes C2 and no
matter what you take with black will
play Knight takes F4 next and there's e
either attack on the bishop on D3 or
four on E2 so it does feel like maybe
there's some tricks here that keep young
look at this he goes Rook D2 you take an
H7 and black has two knights but the end
game is completely lost as White's going
to pick up this a pawn and we'll get two
connected passers on the queen side that
doesn't deserve one exclamation point it
deserves two and a half that was such a
nice realization by Magnus Carlson that
two minor pieces sound more than a rook
and upon Pawn but the end game would
have been winning for white and now we
see a beautiful position where he yes
Magnus is one Pawn ahead but after the
Knight comes back to C6 it's about to be
a second when A7
Falls Janis still fighting though he's
jumping around with his Knights but I
don't think they create any meaningful
threats mag just goes Bishop to C4 maybe
now Rook D7 attacking F7 attacking A7
this one looks over can he just grab his
A7 Pawn he goes Rook D7 first A7 is
falling and as long as he didn't fall
for Knight D2 check he avoided that this
should be a clean victory for Magus
Carlson yeah H4 he just pushed the KN
back and here goes the B Pawn so yon
wisely resigns he keeps time on the
match clock this one is over so let's
see what he can do with white pieces
well hopefully for him he another win
but he will not be so lucky to see
Magnus Mouse slip I think Magnus he's
going to be a little more careful with
his clicks this time around and we have
another Spanish so we might see the same
exact position but without a piece
dropping on
B5 exactly yeah I think it would be wise
for Magnus to just pre moove the move
Pawn takes B5 to make sure sure that he
cannot M slip we see the move Bishop B7
here a different anti- Marshal with D3
and D6 so quiet play here as well black
is currently having the positional
threat Knight A5 which would trap the
bishop for the Knight now you can go
Knight A5 anyway followed by Pawn of C5
to gain space on Queen side that's a
natural plan it looks good for black to
do just that he instead plays the quiet
H6 no Bishop G5 no taking over the D5
Square we're seeing some rerouting they
feel a number of very quiet openings
Benjamin exactly and now he goes C5
expanding on the queen side yon going
Pawn to D4 Magnus taking once is he
going to take twice yes he does black
has this isolated Pawn on D6 but the
pawn on e4 is under a lot of pressure
and black gets pretty good piece
activity here so Black's generally doing
fine that's what we've been talking
about whenever you have an isolated Pawn
you have open files in the adjacent
lines the E file and the C file are in
Black's favor staring at the E4 Pawn The
Rook stares all the way down to the
bishop on C C2 the Knight for black can
jump into C4 and at some moment black
can consider the move D6 to D5 to get
rid of your isolated pawn and blast open
the center and the dark squares that
Bishop on
f8 right but I love this move B3 by he's
stopping the KN from jumping to C4 which
is why the Knight jumps back to C6 and
now he goes Bishop to B2 uh comfortably
developing his bishop and it will always
have an eye on the Knight on F6 so black
canot move their queen as then white can
take and damage Black's Pawn structure
on the king side
okay we see G6 played by Magnus a lot of
us would be too afraid to make that move
opening the dark squares but he's going
to compete for the diagonal with Bishop
to G7 in the near future and meanwhile
Yan plays B4 A4 at some point could be
on the docket I think the black is
completely fine right
now yeah Bishop G7 so let's see I guess
A4 now his idea was actually to go
Bishop to B3 but Robert can black take
on e4 I suppose he's looking at some
stuff connected with Bish takes seven
and queen of three down the line but
does it work it's a big question right
now that Magnus is working to figure out
because Knight E4 it does look like you
can get away with this as Bishop takes
F7 won't be able to play with check
because the bishop is loose on D4 these
are actually some highlevel tactics and
so for Jan he may have overlooked that
detail that he'll have to throw in
Bishop takes G7 King takes G7 and I'm
not sure that he gets away with all of
this yeah Robert what he might have
missed is that after Knight C4 let's say
you take everything and then at the end
you give a check on D4 black can go
Queen F6 and at the end of all of the
variations there will always be a rook
hanging on A1 and now yon has passed the
thing but it's a little bit too late as
now he's down to pawn I don't think you
drew enough arrows on that board so
maybe let's add a few because uh that is
really the tactics that you have to look
out for in true Hikaru Nakamura style
takes takes takes with all the arrows
but it is important that actually after
the series of exchanges The Rook on A1
is loose there so white can't pick up
the piece on e4 and if you can't do this
Benjamin then that means the whole line
is bad for white is there another move
that he can play besides trading
everything
off I don't see it I think in every
variation it's going to be a problem
that The Rook on A1 is hanging so maybe
you have to play like Queen D3 or queen
F3 but black can just play D5 and again
you're down a very clean Pawn so yeah
yon is thinking now but he should have
thought on the last move it's one of
those impulsive decisions where you miss
a tactic in the center and we are seeing
Magnus go for this all of these trades
are happening and instead of a swap on
G7 first queen to D2 he's just going to
be playing this down upon Pawn so
Benjamin great start to this game for
Magnus yeah this is not looking like a
whole lot of fun for y Magnus can just
go Queen G5 force a queen trade going
into an end game up a pawn I mean one
more can you ask for with the black
pieces and again like here there's less
arrows so again in case it takes takes
and queen E4 there was Queen F6 and if
you take there's Queen takes a one yeah
you are responding to chat chat are you
excited for this match and the match
later today Nial sain against Maxim V
Gro so do not go anywhere even when this
match ends we still have so much chess
to be played and well Benjamin I think
right now the chess in this game is all
Magnus he's up a d Pawn it's a healthy
Pawn it's can be protected with move
like Rook C6 a rook to d8 as well how
does Magnus turn this from a slight plus
into a win that's the big question
have yeah let's see how he will do it
Rook C6 looks like a nice move you can
also go Bishop to C2 attacking The Rook
attacking the bishop on B3 it looks like
white has to trade on C2 black
recaptures you can take on G7 and take
on D6 but black plays Rook takes A2 and
there we see them going down that line
black takes on A2 and defends the pawn
A6 so we see Yan playing Pawn A4 first I
love moves like that we're going to lose
the pawn to please take me on A4 The
Rook will go take the D6 pawn and take
the A6 Pawn after that and he's
liquidating so I do think that was a
good decision from yond pishi and it's
two results black either wins this game
or Yan defends accurately and who he
goes Rook A1 instead taking D6 what do
you make of that Rook A1 great move by
Yan Rook C6 by Magnus and now he's
probably going to move his King up
Magnus still has good chance to win but
I think y did a very good job over the
last couple of moves he is now he now
has serious uh chance to hold this
one look at the position oh G4 was given
a question mark the King goes to 6
please take me on G5 says Magnus cuz
then D5 happens that Rook is shut out
and almost
trapped yeah know that was not a good
decision by The Rook on G5 is completely
trapped he goes H4 trying to create a
passer on the king side but I think it's
all going to be a little bit too slow
Magnus going take on B4 but he's got six
seconds uh oh time is of the Ence wait
did he slip
again why would you been Rook B5 there
instead of Rook takes B4 that was a free
Pawn maybe he wants to go D4 and trade
up the Brooks that would be ingenious if
D4 is a winning uh King and Pawn in game
but he instead goes King F6 to the
outside pass Pawn we've talked about
this in previous games that if you did
trade Rooks white would have this H5
push at the right moment one second
Robert he's just lost 20 Tempe like what
did he do why did he not take on B4 it
looked completely winning now this one
should just be a draw it looks like an
easy draw three on two on one side a
pass Pawn on the other but the Rook
stands behind the pass Pawn Benjamin
that was weird we're not used to seeing
Magnus spend so much time like that in
positions with great winning
chances exactly yeah now I guess he's
just going to wait he lost he lost the
time he lost on time and look at Jan's
face he's in disbelief and Magnus is
furious what was he thinking
about I don't know what happened I don't
here's the thing Robert maybe he wanted
to play Rook A1 to H1 but the move is so
far across the board that it took him
too long to make the move that's very
possible and whatever it was Magnus is
not a Happy Camp
he leaves he goes to take a break this
is the Midway point of the 3 plus one
but Benjamin we can't beat around this
big moment here where yanomi has been
the recipient of a mouse slip and then a
win on time I mean what is going on with
Magnus what an absolute shocker Magnus
is still very well in control of this
match but Jan is in it he's only down
two points but Magna should have won
that game if he wins that game he goes
up four points and I think the match is
practically over but now there's still a
chance yand pom she cuts that deficit he
is really doing a good job to keep this
match competitive and we want to shout
out not just this match but what time of
the year it is because we all love
September we get the nicer weather it's
not as hot but it's also subtember to
the end of this month claim up to 30%
off all new Subs on Twitch subscribers
gain access to exclusive Breaktime
content during broadcast unlock new
emotes with Danny's various expressions
mittens and even Magnus and nepo and
score an adree experience on chess.com
don't miss out on the deals this
September subscribe now we will be back
for more from the Spees Championship
presented by coinbase this is Magus
Carlson BR y pomi see you in a
[Music]
few
God it's the same thing every time why
didn't you on assant bro I swear to God
on assant should be forced all my
friends watching and this day is taking
forever play faster if I could move this
Palm backwards it would basically be
Checkmate oh and and draws are dumb I
should be able to flag him no matter how
many times I repeat moves, 14400 years
and it's the same game every time you
know what it's time for some updates I'm
tired of this I'm I'm doing it still
mate is now a win for the player who
gets stalemated you're welcome Eric
Rosen hey it's the Rosen trap pwns can
move backwards why is that never not
been a rule pwns can move backwards now
every
piece should be allowed to on pant what
that's not even possible how ship it
dunzo update enter why is it an ending
there's just two kings on the board what
is this Purgatory this is so awesome
what we're doing here guys we're
changing chest why can't people just
move however they want whenever they
[Music]
want wait what check meate do I not get
to move from now now on C4 actually
[Music]
explodes pawns are weak no more pawns
can promote on the first move update
take that R I'm not sure I made the
users as happy as I thought I would
maybe chess doesn't need an update
Financial systems do need an update
though coinbase is working on just that
reenvisioning an entirely new Financial
system that is decentralized and fully
transparent thank you coinbase for
sponsoring competitive chess and making
events like the speed Chess Championship
possible go to coinbase.com updatethe
system today to learn
more smell chess is coming to chess.com
enchant your pieces with one of two
spells jump or freeze players start with
two jump spells and five freeze spells
which recharge after five moves you may
cast your spell whenever you wish before
making a regular chest move jump is a
spell cast to one square wherein if
there is a piece on that square other
pieces can jump over the Charmed piece
the freeze spell is cast over a 3X3
square area and the pieces in this area
are temporarily Frozen in place combine
your powers of Chess and sorcery to
defeat your
opponent come see what supercell and
chess.com have cooked up in our new
variant spell chess dropping on
September
[Music]
first
[Applause]
[Music]
Magnus Carlson needs no introduction
he's a player whose appearance in the
finals sometimes seems guaranteed but he
hasn't always made it to the speeches
Championship Finals when he has
participated in the event Benjamin we
know that he's had these head-to-head
matchups against Hikaru Nakamura he lost
in 2022 in the finals but before that he
was actually upset before he could
actually reach the final
match yeah for sure in 2020 he lost to
mvl in the semi-finals so was quite a
surprise but we see in 2016 and 2017 he
beat hiar nakura quite convincingly in
2017 actually by a 10 point margin but
it seems like Hikaru has managed to flip
the
script Hikaru has done so well in this
he is five-time reigning champion and
Magnus Carlson would like to take that
title from Nakamura but he first has to
get through yand pomi who suddenly is
only one point away Benjamin it's been
surprising there's been a mouth slip
there's been and lost on time yand pomi
doesn't care how he gets it done as long
as the winds stack up exactly and we are
off to another game we again see yon
going back to the petol defense but yeah
Magnus has been in full control but yeah
some unfortunate losses we saw like you
said that that blunder also that time
they're lost on time I I don't know what
happened there Robert again like do you
think he he just forgot about the clock
for a second I think maybe your point
was a good one that he looked to bring
that Rook all the way across the board
and it's a distant move move hard to get
off in time when you only have a couple
seconds but no matter what the reason
was maybe we will have a chance to ask
Magnus the match is getting closer
instead of yan spiraling out of control
he is now keeping this match close he is
only down by a couple games two game
margin so it's going to be a tougher
fight than Magnus would have hoped
for right so we see to move night B2
defending the Knight on F3 perhaps that
move like Rook E8 by Yan I like this one
now he can recapture the king maybe that
move the king over to d8 so then he can
bring this Rook on h8 into the game he
goes Knight takes E8 it looks a little
bit passive at first glance but he can
always rout his KN with let's say Knight
E7 and then trade of the Bishops with
Bishop to
F5 and that Rook on A1 if it were
already on E1 we'd be talking about an
advantage for white because you're first
the open file but Magnus expands on the
queen side my Rook may be in its
starting square but I can develop it
from where it sits let's push pawns up
the board A4 Knight B3 and so on this is
a very Magnus style
position exactly he's slowly Patrol
improving but I also really like how yon
is rerouting his pieces he goes n E7 now
he can go Bish to F5 or King F7 move up
his King his Rook can potentially come
into the game and Magnus is gaining
space over here on the queen side but I
don't really see what he's achieved just
yet does he want the bishop pair like d
takes C4 Knight takes C4 the bishop on
D6 he doesn't really have too many
squares to go to you don't want to go up
to B4 The Rook will go to B1 and kick it
around some more but if you take on D6
and the Knight takes back black is fully
developed with no real weaknesses that I
can
see right and that is why Yan goes
Bishop B6 he does not mind the trade
Magnus now goes Bishop to A3 but I think
Yan is doing absolutely fine here like
you said Magnus has the bishop air but
his isolated Pawn on D4 deprives him of
an advantage so Rook D7 nice move by Yan
defending the pawn on C7 and white needs
to be careful because Knight coming to
D5 that Knight protects C7 it also could
jump to F4 the B five Pawn its Advance
is looking pretty good but it can also
be vulnerable as maybe at some point
black can team up against it I think all
the black's pieces AR perfect
squares yeah Knight D5 nice move here by
yon he wants to go Knight F four attack
that Bishop perhaps the bishop will have
to move back to F1 but he can also the
the Knight on D5 also defends the pawn
on C7 so Magnus drops the bishop back to
F1 preemptively and let's see what yon
is going to do here he should be doing
fine knight4 perhaps he wants to go to
C3 I think Yan wants to win this game
the way his Knights are hopping up the
board why not the white pawns they push
forward but they're not queening anytime
soon and they can be weaknesses as now
the pawns are not in contact with one
another and those Knights are very
jumpy and Robert are we going to see a
draw here Bishop D3 by Magnus Knight D6
this is an invitation to repetition I
mean yon of course either player could
deviate here with with another move it
would be such a strange draw but Magnus
he should realized that right now he's
no better that his isolated Pawn is a
long-term weakness that it's not clear
how he would play for a win he pushes
forward with A6 Benjamin that's a move
that can backfire because now you have
the cemented Pawn structure unless that
Knight goes say like E1 C2 B4 C6
something like that I don't know how it
ever will get to C6 I feel like the
static Pawn structure should favor
Black yeah I'm starting to like Jan's
position more and more we see him
expanding here on the king side King H2
a clever move by Magnus so he can go G3
and the pawn on H3 will not be hanging
he now goes H4 yon has to go G4 to keep
his Pawn structure intact kicking the
Knight away but this F4 square has been
weakened and Magnus will be looking to
take advantage of with maybe Knight E1
to G2 and potentially Knight F4 if this
night moves and look at this Knight F5
the Knight was kicked away from
defending the D4 Pawn so the Yan says
why not let me go after that very Pawn
in the center and I think Knight C2 is a
little bit worrisome for Yan because you
want to move move your knight from D5
and he does that but at some point
Knight B4 to C6 you have to be very very
careful with your A7 Pawn if that's
Pawn's lost white has a very Advanced
passer yeah so we've got a pretty
interesting position here he goes Bishop
to D5 white cannot play Knight B4 just
yet like you said it would hang the pawn
on D4 okay now Knight E3 Bishop F3 I
like this bishop here on F3 it's nicely
cemented here by these pawns at some
point Yan can consider taking but Robert
look at the clock he's way up on time
Yan continues to be a speed demon C6
here looks like a very good move to my
eyes a b C6 Knight takes C6 and that
pawn A6 is a future Target the B Pawn is
sprung free the D4 Pawn is loose the
white king is in trouble and C5 a very
similar idea I think that b takes C6 is
likely and Jan he has the upper
hand right exactly he's Tak on C6 he's
going to recapture with a knight I like
what Jan is doing he's playing quickly
and confidently and what's great for him
is that he's actually out playing Magnus
a little bit in these end games the pawn
D4 is weak Magnus therefore goes Knight
C2 I think a correct decision to not
allow this Knight to jump into C6 as it
would put massive pressure on the white
position also keep in mind the D Pawn
for the moment of spin as it would hang
the bishop on D3 so let's see how yon
will tighten the screws here he brings
his King up in the center white does the
same I like the choice for both of them
where's progress how does either side
move forward is it F5 F4 for black just
trying to create a secondary weakness in
the position
wait what is Pawn tak4 now Magnus can
recapture with a knight and you can take
an F3 black is talk with all of these
weaknesses did you see Yan he was very
upset with himself he chastised himself
he completely overlooked Knight takes D4
grabbing this bishop on
F3 yeah now Magnus takes on F3 he
recaptures but look at this Knight D4
shutting the Rook on Magnus now wants to
go King E2 and Robert what has happened
yon was in the driver's seat he was
putting a bit of pressure now all of a
sudden it looks like he might just be
lost king2 is coming after Rook moose
there's Rook C7 and I don't see how
you're keeping this together one tiny
oversight loses Yan the game I mean he
must be in a losing position Magnus
about 30 seconds himself we saw him lose
on time that was shocking it's not going
to happen
again yeah King D3 he's seconding the F2
Pawn but you don't really care about
that it's very difficult for black to
create a passer on the king side Rook A3
I guess you just go King up to C4 or
here or to C2 everything looks winning
go King E4 this opponent A7 is going to
drop Robert and that should be the G
game the Knight doesn't even have any
good moves you have to go Knight G8 but
there might even be some ideas to
Checkmate the black king not right now
but Knight F5 Rook G7 would be a mating
net if not for Rook A4 check but just
take A7 you're easily winning as black
is tied
down this is so unfortunate for Yan
again like he has to avoid these
blunders he goes rookie one now white
cannot take this there rookie one so
Magnus takes the a point and Rook D7
search position paralyzing the Knight as
it can no longer go to D6 and he's going
to bring his Knight in A7 next and I
think at the very best for black he's
down a full piece and he's not even
getting the B5 Pawn now this is over
Magnus up a full piece Jan presses the
resign button but what an unfortunate
loss he he should not have lost this one
no I mean he just completely overlooked
that Knight takes D4 was allowed it was
a check it was able to take that Bishop
on F3 and that was a really bad turnover
events for Yan Who's down by three
points so Benjamin we keep talking about
it if mag is going to you points you
can't them back and that's what Yan just
did and he is now in some
trouble exactly like you're going to be
at played in some games that can happen
but you shouldn't gift him points like
by making blunders losing out of the
opening you got to try to play as tight
as possible we see yon here playing with
white pieces I like what he's doing
going for Russ Lio Magnus going for the
setup with the pawns on the queen side
and Bishop E6 so let's see if young can
put some pressure here with the white
pieces but yeah that was such a costly
throw if he had won that game it would
have been back to two points but now the
margin is three again and three it's not
insurmountable but at some point you
know you you have to make a comeback and
Magnus is so good in bullet chest that
you can't even count on that you know
some players you play against them you
think it's going to be a topsy turby
final stretch we did see Wesley so take
down ala fuia in bullet that was
surprising to the masses so it is
possible and I think hikaro spoke on
that saying that nobody would have given
Wesley a chance to beat Al res in bullet
he was able to
make it even they went into an
Armageddon game which Wesley won so Yan
still his chances even if we get a
bullet and he's down by a couple games
but he can't afford to keep losing he
cannot allow the lead to balloon to say
four or five
points no for sure I think what what
people sometimes forget in the bullet
portion is that it's one plus one if it
would be one plus zero I think ell reso
would be a big big favorite against
Wesley but with the one second incent
that makes all the difference it's still
normal it's still very similar to 3 plus
one they would not be you know flagging
things of that nature and that is why
Wesley managed to beat Ali Resa I like
what Jana is doing here again he's
playing quickly and I think he's
preparing a D4 or B4 push at some point
why not open up that darkart square
Bishop uh if the king castles then it's
hard to move that C5 Pawn as The Rook
will be loose at the end of the line so
D4 does seem to be a threat and Magnus
he's spending his time Yan up about a
minute on the clock this this feels like
a game where he has chances once
again right but what about this move
Bishop G4 here Robert you threatened to
take an F3 and double white pawns and
now the Knight on F3 is spin as you put
this Rook on one I don't see a good way
to get out of it in case of Queen E2
black has Knight G5 so that looks pretty
unpleasant for yon perhaps he should
have played H3 on one of the last couple
of
moves and whoa magnez the castle inste
we do see D4 and the position was very
close and now suddenly it's blasting
open the Knight on C4 is under attack
the C5 Pawn is under attack The Rook on
f8 is behind that C5 pawn and we are
seeing some trades here but B no B4 is
not going to be available to Black is
it wait I am quite surprised by what by
what yon just did why did he trade on B5
he could have also just played Knight E3
right away I guess the difference is
that now B4 is not a move as you take
and the C Pawn will be pinned but Magnus
takes on D4 he's sacking in exchange but
look at this Robert if you recapture
take take on D C2 and take on B3 and you
not only have the bishop air but you
also have two outside passers this looks
great for Magnus with that Bishop on f8
supporting them from afar the A4 B4 A3
you take this Knight on C2 and the
bishop on f8 is actually doing a great
job of Defending those passers so this
looks tragic for Yan and perhaps you
know you think about it you have a rook
for just one minor piece and one Pawn
you think you're ahead but it's not just
about the point value it's about how
strong these pawns are and while A4 got
a question mark I think that we can all
tell that white is definitely in trouble
but Benjamin he allowed D5 maybe that's
why A4 was not the best
move yeah perhaps he had to move like
Bishop to H6 attacking The Rook if the
Rook moves to hang the Knight now we see
Magnus going F5 okay he's playing pretty
actively but he's also loosening up his
own position Knight D2 nice move by Yan
he wants to take the bishop on B3 get
rid of the bishop pair and then the
pawns can can become a little bit loose
and look at the clock Robert all of a
sudden y's up a minute so this one is
far from over and Bishop H6 no longer
works cuz Knight takes B3 and after a
takes B3 then Knight to E3 those Double
B pawns are bad news for black you can't
allow white to take this bishop on B3 I
don't think so maybe you should take the
Knight on C2 but then you're worried
about the open C file some counter
chances for
white exactly so goes Knight to D6 I
guess this idea is that in case white
takes and then moves the Knight you can
take the pawn on e4 four so let's see
what Yan is going to do here you can
take an F5 but then black can escape
with the bishop with Bishop takes D5 so
Yan goes Knight E3
first okay so if you take on e4 with the
pawn the Knight takes B3 so he goes for
this
anyway but is there a knight D2 somehow
coming all right so we see Bishop E4 by
Magnus ATT attacking The Rook where do
you go with the Rook wherever you go
you're going to get forked if you go to
F1 there's a fork on D2 if you go to C1
there there's Knight C3 followed by
Knight E2 so this looks quite
problematic why is that a question mark
I don't see what you do Rook C1 for
example I think here you can just play
Knight D2 Rook B2 Bishop A3 and that's
game over that's game over yeah Magnus
is already up a pawn or so for the
exchange or wait no no he's up two pawns
so if he wins back the exchange here he
will be up a clean two pawns this B Pawn
will be super strong so like I said
Robert this one looks to be over it is
not and you can see it on Yan's face he
is not very happy and Magnus he's about
to lead by Four Points unless there is
some way to make a draw but I don't
think so you're going to take on E3 take
on D5 it's going to be two extra pawns
and one's in the center one's a passer
on the queen side and this just going to
be an easy conversion for Magnus Carlson
exactly he's just in town with Rook
takes D5 defending the PA on E5 and on
B5 Rook C3 by yon played very quickly
but this one is completely over Rook d8
search a nice move by Magnus he's giving
up the eom but he's putting the Rook
behind the passer that's where he want
and now he moves his King up and this
game is over Robert right because the
white king will have to continue going
to the queen side but he doesn't even
get there in time and then the black
king even if you were able to surround
the pawn can go back towards the king
side to win the game so this looks like
a problem King C1 The Rook releases to
E8 or A8 and we see a win for Magnus
Carlson from the black side Benjamin Jan
he's shaky right now and this could get
out of hand and if he doesn't stop the
bleeding yeah all of a sudden it's uh
it's a four-point gap that's quite hey
after the break it was only two points I
thought Jon was still having a very good
chance he also had chances in that black
game in the patch off but we saw how he
took on D4 a little too quickly and
again he's just losing games in an
unnecessary Manner and Magnus is just
more
consistent he is indeed and we see the
this game it looks very solid but we
have have a Sicilian Defense so it was a
nidorf then it turns into a dragon likee
position and black has no weaknesses
white similarly doesn't really have any
weaknesses but white has more control so
what's Black's plan in a position like
this it's a good question I mean I also
struggle sometimes in these positions
like what is the plan he goes Knight E5
to C4 all right so white can stop that
with B3 but I guess then Queen C7 is
annoying attacking the Knight on C3 so
let's see how Magnus is going to deal
with this he can also Knight C4 it's
really not a big deal but then black
gets The Rook to C4 he can double and
even triple on a CF so I guess that's
what Y is going for right here yeah
Knight C4 it does get black the bishop
hair but once you swap there's also
these E5 tactics that you have to be
worried about so Yan putes Bishop on C6
but then the question is why is the
Knight on E5 the Knight doesn't seem
like it's really doing all that much
there if it can't jump forward
anymore exactly F3 nice move by Magnus
solidifying the pawn E4 now Magnus wants
to go A5 create a clamp on the queen
side as Bishop can always slide into B6
at the right moment and look at this
he's played F4 and he's given Yan a
bunch of weaknesses on the king side all
of a sudden this looks really good for
white yeah maybe the claim is that
there's some counterplay you if you go
after the H5 pawn it takes a bit of time
it's kind of got some spasky Fisher
Vibes to it but the Knight came back to
D4 so quickly going after the bishop
Knight F5 going after the other Bishop
looks very worrisome for the black king
not a big fan of this position for
Yan n me neither Knight C5 was played
attacking the pawn on e4 so Magnus
straights on C6 and now plays E5 taking
advantage of the pin along the defile
you cannot take that pawn at some point
maybe Magnus can take Queen C8 maybe now
Knight D5 threatening a deadly Fork
which is why y plays rookie eight wow
this is hanging on by a thread for Yan
pami but his position even though his
double ice H pawns look bad I think he
has good activity the queen of Rook on
the C file at some point you have to
watch out for your C2 Pawn being loose
you can't push the C Pawn because Knight
B3 tactics um if you take on D6 the
bishop on G7 is now out in the open
suddenly I believe a little bit more in
Yan's
position exactly yeah this queen can
also slide into F5 defending the the the
king side a little bit Magnus does not
have a knockout here in case he takes on
D6 yonu not Al maybe he can even
recapture with the Rook as Knight C7
there's Rook takes and at the end of it
all the bishop on E3 is hanging so I
don't know what Magnus should do here
and look at the clock robbert all of a
sudden he's down a minute and this makes
sense this time management for jannis
paying off it's a complicated position I
think that black could be better in a
few turns the white king even though it
looks safe some of those dark squares in
front of it are very loose and so Magnus
takes the Knight on C5 and I would take
with the Rook on C5 because if you took
with the pawn then the bishop on G7 was
locked in now that Bishop it slices
across the diagonal and has some
play right so he takes on D6 and forces
y captured the pawn Yan is a very ugly
structure here he's got these isolated
pawns all over the board but his Rook is
active his Queen is active his Bishop is
open as well so he might not be doing
too bad here rookie one nice move by
Magnus though reinforcing the threat of
97 check and giving up the B2 Pawn but
he doesn't care about that PA or maybe
he does the way he just put his hand up
he's maybe recognizing that Bishop takes
B2 is a possibility because that Rook on
A1 is under attack and after Rook to B1
is there some kind of
swap on E1 and Bishop C3 I'm not really
sure
there maybe no Bishop C3 right away
loses due to Rook K C8 and Knight K C3
so I wonder what exactly yon could do
there maybe you can take on C2 is that
no there's Rook C8 again I I don't know
he plays King h8 but that looks really
passive now you just hand Magnus a b
position and it's clear Bishop takes B2
was available both by magnus's Body
Language and the question mark given to
King h8 not an easy move to play to
remove your only defender of your king
to the other side of the board but
Magnus Carlson trades Rooks now puts his
Pawn on C3 and strategically Benjamin I
think we could say that white is winning
strategically but there are some holes
in White's King side on the dark squares
and it's not easy to break through when
you have to worry about your own
King exactly goes Queen D3 slowly but
surely improving the position however
now he can no longer go Rook D1 Queen C6
and Knight E3 Yan pieces are becoming a
bit more active but overall it looks
great for Magnus black is this ugly Pawn
structure with isolated Pawns in the
center and on the king side this Knight
can always move to F5 which is why yon
played Queen to D7 that being said
though it's not that easy to bring this
rook in as if you go Rook e one you're
going to hang this a pawn and that's why
went A5 but it gave black the B5 Square
rook
six4 and you see Magnus he recognized it
as soon as he played the move he was
like what am I
thinking wait does one who completely
turn around all of a sudden y up a pawn
these pawns are on dark first queen E6
nice move offering the trade of Queens
Magnus doesn't mind the trade of Queens
but he wants to trade on his terms
Bishop C3 I guess takes is not good
because of Bishop D4 o that's a nasty
looking pin white maybe hanging on by a
thread here and look at the clock by the
way Magnus down to 15 seconds to Yan
minute
plus yeah what do you do here what do
you do again you don't want to trade he
plays F5 okay Yan can trade he can also
just move the queen as now the dark
shares have been weakened even more I
would go Queen E7 defend all your pawns
the B4 Pawn is loose their pins the
queen H4 check is available to go after
that B4 Pawn he plays Queen F6 but why
would you give up the B7
Pawn what was that he gives a B7 and A6
Magnus goes king of three I don't know
what J's on here Magnus seems to be
completely fine and king of three maybe
not the most precise but in time trouble
looks like a good move and if you take
on E3 King takes E3 that looks like we
should be heading towards dville because
the white king will probably see tons of
checks and not be able to successfully
Escape yeah black can pick up some pawns
maybe the pawn F five but white should
always have sufficient counterplay as
they're going to get a passer on the
queen side so I don't think there's
anything more here than a draw for Jon I
mean slightly disappointing for Magnus
he was in control for most of the game
but uh I think if you're yaan you might
be kicking yourself as this might have
been an opportunity to close the gap a
little bit Jan went for a win with D5
the engine didn't love it but he is
maybe just able to force a draw at the
stage with checking on the dark squares
but Ma Magnus he's the only one who can
win this position okay Queen takes B4
there goes the pawn with check though
this one should be a draw I don't see a
way for Magnus to get out that being
said wait there's no good check now so
Yos King G7 Queen B6 check D4 wait this
is still a three years old game yeah
whose Pawn is better both are pass Queen
E5 is a very nice
move okay okay you hang the pawn with
check you canot take on D4 so he goes
there goes A5 there taking A5 and you're
playing for two results now sudden oh
Queen trade because Black's Pawn
structure is bad this going to be a sun
dial but the king stays in touch with
the queen Benjamin as long as the queen
stays on D5 I have a hard time imagine
white losing this
game okay Queen H7 he could have taken
on H5 as G2 is not hanging because of
Queen di of s this one should be a draw
because Black's Pawn structure is so bad
yeah Queen F5 normally up upon an end
game should lead to a win but not with
double isolated H pawns like this and
now the queen trade is offered good try
though by Yan and now it should be an
easy draw yeah this one was an easy draw
if black had doubled F pawns there would
have still been been a chance but
doubled H pawns I think there's nothing
you can do here the king of five the
king just steps back and uh again if you
oh yeah there's nothing to be done here
if they're double F pawns you would have
the F3 move instead we see a draw yand
pomi he had a missed opportunity once
mag just blundered that B4 Pawn so both
players have not been fully accurate but
this is going to be our final game
before the bullet there are less than
three minutes remaining in the 3 plus
one so Benjamin I think for yanami he
needs to find a win
here exactly we see an English opening
Magnus playing the system with Knight F6
and pawn to H6 B4 I think jannis
following the game between prag and
Magnus in the World Cup in the in the
finals night D4 A4 here by uh by yon but
yon needs at least a win here to close
down the Gap a little bit with three
points I still think that Magnus is a
heavy heavy favorite but at least there
would be some
chances he needs to get a victory to cut
this to three he'll just feel better
about himself if he's able to be in that
kind of Striking Distance but Magnus he
plays A6 he develops his rook in
starting Square he wants to open the a
file and I feel like this position it's
it's not one of those tactical melees
it's a situation where both sides are
playing small waiting moves hoping to
improve their
position exactly rookie at a crafty
little move by Magnus he's waiting for
Yano takas now this will open up the E
fall for his rookie might also consider
to move B4 here I think that is the only
reason why he's supposed to think
because otherwise you just take the
KN yeah so what is going on right now uh
we see that Magnus is choosing between
these two but he plays B4 so he takes
the road let travel by and Yan was
surprised yeah exactly B4 I'm sure that
yon had anticipated this move Pawn takes
D4 maybe uh okay so Bishop f8 the bishop
drops back I think black should be doing
quite fine here white is a little bit
more active but this Pawn on A5 is
isolated so Magnus can try to Target it
later yon is preparing to meet C6 with
Knight A3 to C4 which looks pretty
reasonable you put some pressure on D5
and you further defend the pawn on A5 oh
look at this move Bishop takes F6 Queen
takes F6 Bishop takes E4 is this a pawn
sacrifice or what exactly does black
have in store well The Rook on the pawn
on E5 is hanging at the end so we see
yon taking on e4 but I think here if you
take on D1 and take on e4 black should
be doing pretty fine maybe y can
consider the take and go Rook d8 to
freeze black but is there well is there
a way for black to crawl out that looks
scary there may be a rook A4 move to
counter pin some of the pieces and
perhaps there not enough pieces
remaining for white to really have the
upper hand but it does look a little
Annoying yeah so I think that is why
Magnus has postive thing it looks quite
scary okay he does take on e4 let's see
if Jan is going to go for it take on e4
and take on d8 that being said there's
no immediate threat as Bishop E4 is not
available and maybe black just has the
time to go let's say F6 King F7 followed
by Rook E8 and then Black's doing very
well strategically with the bishop air
exactly what Magnus goes for so you
spotted it he did as well and now as you
said the king gets out with to F7 the A5
Pawn is a target black has the bishop
hair and after King F7 the next move can
be Rook to E8 just to trade off those
Rooks and F3 by y trying to kick the
Rook away from the fourth ring so
there's Bri B4 but Magnus does not full
for it he goes Rook to A4 stopping the
Bishop from coming here and I think he's
doing quite well here Knight C2 you can
trade here and then play King of seven
afterwards that being said how do you
unpin yourself you're in the back rank
you're going to play Bishop E7 and when
The Rook goes to h8 you're going to go
Bishop back to f8 and then shut the door
on the rook in the corner so it's
actually quite straightforward very
nicely done by Magnus King F7 Bishop E7
and The Rook is flushed out of there
yeah I love that idea Robert I don't see
what yon should do in the meantime right
now he has to recapture with one of his
pieces I suppose with the Knight King F7
is going to come maybe like Knight B3
but then Bishop B7 The Rook has to move
and Bishop f f and it looks like Magnus
has a very comfortable Advantage he's
got the bishop air spawn on E5 is a
little bit weak so it's looking tough
for Yan here Knight takes A1 to B3 I
like that the best but I don't think
it's that good of a position the bishop
pair is just strong and once that second
Bishop enters the light Bishop I feel
like white is going to be on the
defensive and Yan doesn't look very
happy now Bishop B7 great find here by
Magnus The Rook has to move I guess
maybe you have to move it all the way
back but then after Bishop B6 black is
in full control like you said in case
Rook h8 you go Bishop f8 shot The Rook
out the bishop is going to join the
action and black is uh comfortably
better and then the question goes to how
did whoa he allowed his Rook to be shut
off back
there that surprising to
me okay Benjamin this this looks bad for
white I can't like black just play C5
here and start pushing those
pawns C5 is a nice move I think what Jan
is banging on is that in case uh Magnus
goes Bishop B6 then you go Knight C5
taking advantage Al the fact that this
bishop is pin again as The Rook on a is
hanging there we go Knight C5 attacking
the pawn on B7 so what does Magnus do
here you can go Bishop C8 back and I'm
sure you're fine but otherwise I mean
Rook B8 looks kind of passive and
actually maybe you can take go Bishop B4
I think Magnus missed Knight C5 the way
he slowed down and he look at his body
language he's missing ideas and it's
really irking him but if you play Bishop
to C8 and you just it's kind of a
recognition that something went wrong
instead he gives up the B7 Pawn cuz
Bishop C8 Rook takes E2
check uhuh right so in case white takes
there's here but there's A6 though you
can take an E2 king of one but the a
pawn could be scary also there are most
like Knight d8 hang hanging in the
position good point with a knight check
this is looking very tricky and if yand
pomi wants to cut into this lead that
Magnus Carls has he has to play Knight
takes B7 s he goes for it I still think
that black should be easily okay here
but Rook takes
E2 oh sorry what Magnus can always do is
perhaps trade at the right moment go
Rook B8 although if he does so right
away there might be Bishop B4 and black
all of a sudden is lost but yeah he
should still be completely fine but he
has to be
careful and he does does go for the E
Pawn and he's thinking after King to F1
but what is wrong with Rook A2 Knight d8
check King
ah King E8 Knight takes
C6 barely G4 by Yan I think he rushed a
c C5 great move by Manus he wants take
on B7 followed by Rook B8 and now
there's no longer Bishop to B4 maybe yon
should have played like Bishop A5 to set
up 98 but I think now Magnus is doing
great yeah because Magnus is just going
to steal a pawn and that Rook on h8 is
trapped what do you do about that like
The Rook is simply stuck in the
corner I don't see move he sacks it on
f8 what and think takes C5 but Robert
this has to be lost the Aon is going to
disappear very soon and you will be down
a very clean exchange well maybe he gets
Bishop b68 Oh What a fine from
Magnus What a fine he's going to be up a
clean exchange here and this one is
going to I mean this right now is just a
matter of technique I'm pretty sure this
end game has to be winning he goes at
five to break up the pawns it's still
require some work though to to actually
win this game yeah perhaps there is a
chance here for Yan I mean I was looking
at the eval bar well now it says he
losing so before it wasn't all the way
down there but look at this he's going
to go cut this king off and then bring
his own King in he goes G5 that gives
him a weakness on on the G5 Square
though but I assume that sooner or later
white is going to lose his Pawn on F3 I
feel like Magnus just knows when
positions are winning he he just
protected his G pawn and he'll bring his
King in like right now and then if the
bishop somehow attacks the pawn again
he'll bring his Rook back to D5 but
that's not happening
exactly okay so for the moment Jan is
hanging on you sit with the bishop here
but I assume that at some moment you're
going to end in end up in
zuk okay how do you ah that's a nice
move if you take then check and King
E3 that's sick that's such a nasty way
to win the game which Magnus Carlson
does and he currently leads by Five
Points over Yap pomi look at Yan's face
that's a man who has been facing off
against Magnus Carlson for hours it's
not fun when you're on the losing
end no certainly not looking like fun
here for Yan he still had some chances
but he's down five points in match
Robert I don't see him making a comeback
here it's going to be difficult when
you're facing Magnus Carlson who is
unhappy with this play that much has
been clear he's missed things they
haven't been necess huge blunders but
they've been inaccuracies and he strives
for Perfection but when you're playing
yand pomi leading by five points that
should feel as close to Perfection as
you could Poss possibly hope for it's a
big lead we only have one time control
left 30 minutes of bullet Benjamin what
can Yan Naomi possibly do to make it a
comeback I think the first game is going
to be critical if Yan wins the first
game with the with the black pieces he
still has a chance he could get some
momentum win one game after another you
know in bullet you might easily get
tilted so the first game is is critical
if he wins the one he has a chance if he
loses I think the match is practically
over I think that he needs to get some
energy he needs to get that Breakin get
refreshed and while we're speaking of
energy we want to take a moment to shout
out our new partner to the speed Chess
Championship
ag1 ag1 is your daily support of key
Health functions from mental performance
to energy and the immune system it's the
one product that does the work of many
to find out more visit drink a1.com
chess or use the command ag1 in chat
thank you to ag1 for sponsoring the
secc we will be right back here in the
speed Chess Championship presented by
coinbase this has been a fun match it's
Magnus Carlson versus Yanda pomi bullet
coming up after the
[Music]
break
this right here is how I use chessable
and why I've been using it for a long
time I mean if you look up here I
actually have my streak it says
1,231 days right you're going to forget
a lot of the things that are in the book
chessable came around when I got on
chessable it's literally I was already
doing that so this is now a game changer
because I can do it faster it's online
it's in front of me all of my books are
here there's going to be folders now so
I can categorize by white black and all
tactics in game but I literally have
everything in one area you see I'm
scrolling here this is why I like to so
they like how many chessable books you
got I'm like all of them how I use
chessable is actually I do a lot for the
opening training I do tactics on here I
do calculation I do ingame I do
everything but the database all my
training on here all the time chessable
is the wave this is why I like to use
chessable it's actually helped me I
remember even online I was only like
capping out at 2350 almost 2400 and in
Blitz and bullet my chest com is 26 with
a high of 2774 and bullet and I blame
all of this like success really is just
working on chessable just being honest
with
[Music]
you love playing chess variants or just
looking for something new join us for
the variants Community series every two
months we'll be featuring a different
variant in a series of events and
competitions learn a new variant and
compete against other players for prize
money or just play for fun look for
Community Arenas streamer Arenas and
Championship events six weekly Arena
tournaments held every Thursday will be
followed by a championship event with
cash prizes including a $11,000 first
place prize the third and final weekly
Arenas will be streamer Arenas featuring
gifted Subs as prizes win any of these
events to qualify for the championship
the variant Community series kicks off
on September 7th with King of the Hill
we the first to occupy the center wins
the game but getting checkmated still
loses and join the variant club today to
learn more about upcoming events how to
participate and much much more see you
in the arena un check
[Music]
t.com
he
[Music]
[Applause]
he
[Music]
welcome back to the speed CHS
Championship presented by coin base
Magnus Carlson may not be in his chair
but he is in the lead in his match
against Yap pomi there you now see the
number one rated player in the world it
has been his summer Benjamin he's played
in five events in recent months and look
at his results he won two Champions
chess tour events he won the super
United Grand chest tour rapid and Blitz
he won the World Cup second in the bull
chest Championship he's been on an
absolute
Terror exactly and the only time he did
not win he was stopped by hekar Nakamura
in the finals of the bulletz
championship but right now he's on his
way to a very smooth victory over Yan
Pachi he's up five points in a match Jon
will need a miracle comeback here Robert
he'll need to do something differently
than he has been because Jon even when
he's been able to string together a
couple good games Magnus is able to just
get right back up and steal a victory so
for Magnus Carlson a five-point lead
it's hard to imagine him letting this
slip but it's bullet chess Mouse slips
lost on time disconnects they can all go
one player's
Direction and we are off Magnus opens up
with a London system Yan responding with
the cop with Bishop F5 KN of three so
let's see Queen B6 here by yon hitting
the pawn on B2 which is always a little
bit awkward to defend right because a
queen B3 black throws the pawn up to C4
and so Magnus he says I'm going to
defend by attacking something else and
now Queen can slide to that dag goes to
B1 the engine didn't like it but Queen
B1 Magnus he chose to put it on that
square yeah G6 and Bishop G7 by Yan so
that whenever This Night Moves there
will be to move Bishop to F5 Bishop B2
by Mangus perhaps there will something
better for Yan but he still has a very
comfortable position here out of the
opening against Salon can't complain if
you have this from the black side and
now the bishop can and does slide out to
the F5 the queen is under threat but
that's why the bishop steps in between
so trades seem to help White's cause but
B2 is loose here can you capture it you
can take but white is banging on the
Move Rook fb1 if the queen moves you can
take the pawn on B7 so let's see if Yan
is going to take he can also of course
continue to improve his position with a
move like Rook
A8 Rook a to C8 always a natural move A4
expansion on the queen side and A6 that
was a move that cost Yan in the world
championship match remember it the exact
structure like this this was a problem
for
him yeah so now the idea is that in case
you take the P A5 white wants to go Pawn
takes C5 and if he recaptured the queen
there would have been B4 Magnus now
steps his Knight in the center with
Knight E5 and I think slowly but surely
Magnus is gaining the upper hand here as
his pieces are slightly more active that
Queen on A7 it's offside it's not really
helping out in the position and black
shuts it down with C4 and we're going to
have a closed game here of maneuvering
chess but this should be good for white
who controls an important Pawn break B3
and E4 both of them it's up to
White exactly Bishop G such an
unpleasant move and now he breaks in the
center with the move E4 yon has to take
on E5 but it looks so unpleasant White's
going to recapture your Knights under
attack oh he takes on F5 right away he
just wants to open up the black king and
he's bring his Knight to F3 this looks
like a French defense with that
backwards E6 Pawn now this looks
terrible you cannot take an F5 he goes
B5 but this might give him even more
weaknesses Magnus goes Knight F3 but
look at this Robert he's up a pawn and
the D5 PA is so weak Yan missed the Rook
on C it was loose so he couldn't
recapture on E5 now suddenly black
trying to drum up some counterplay over
there the A5 Pawn is gone the C3 Pawn
may be next but is the black king going
to
survive I don't know Robert it looks
like if this knight ever lands on a five
or there goes the D Pawn oh and there
goes R that's one game yes he gets the
Rook with check he takes the other Rook
nice tactical awareness from Magnus
Carlson and I don't think yapi has the
draw here it looks like Rook d8 would
win he resigns Magnus is now up by
six yeah so let's see if Magnus can come
back if sorry Yan can come back with
white piece he plays the Vienna game all
right Magnus goes for his quick Knight
A5 move going after the bishop but yeah
that was a very smooth victory for
Magnus and I like that Yan he is mixing
it up with Queen to H5 he's Hing the E5
P but Knight to B4 the queen on D1 does
an important job now black gets quick
development I like stealing material and
bullets so Benjamin I think from Yan's
perspective it's a successful
opening right he's up a pawn here but
Magnus has very easy piece play his
Bishop drops back to f8 and his Bishop
on B7 is is so active always putting
pressure on the white King on G1 Rook E8
I love that move he just wants to go
Rook A8 maybe Rook G6 robbert I think in
bullet this is really a dream position
for black like all of your moves come so
natural yeah suddenly it's really
difficult and he blundered the H3 Pawn
F3 Queen takes H3 thank you very much
for the attack and the material and you
could see the frustration on Yan pom's
face he can't believe what's happening
here but nobody can believe the level of
chest that Magnus Carls intends to show
no he's play so well and so quickly look
at the clock Rober he's up to 58 seconds
it's it's incredible that he's just
playing all of these moves instantly and
yeah that's just his his instinct is on
another level and F5 kicks the Knight
out of there opening up that Bishop on
B7 once more the Knight goes to G5 but I
feel like black just bring that Knight
back to D5 F4 threatens to win the piece
o this is terrible for
white exactly everything is so super
loose he goes KN H3 but there's got to
be oh look at this R34 hitting the
bishop and The Rook that is a sick find
he just gives up an exchange to win a
pinned Knight the Knight on night H3
sorry the pawn on G2 is Pinn to the king
that is so
nasty yeah and there's nothing you can
do here with right Yana's going to lose
another game and he's going to go down
seven
points I mean just unbelievable when
Magnus plays like this there's nobody
who can stop him and we mean nobody he
is now going to be up a minor piece Yan
has to throw in the towel seveno lead
from Magnus
Carlson yeah to be fair there is still
that guy hiar Nakamura who you know is
very much on par with him with bullet
but you know Magnus is playing out of
his mind right now playing Super quickly
finding all of these tactics in just a
blink of an
eye and look at this position there's a
black knight out into White's camp on B4
it's kind of Trapped but it's hard to
attack CU C5 there it goes you defend it
if aant the Knight takes
back right the Knight is now safe but
the D6 PA is week which is why Magnus
goes Bishop to F4 y has to go either I
was going to say either E5 or D5 but he
goes Knight E8 that looks a little bit
passive and white goes E5 if he take on
E5 the Queens would be traded and white
would take back on E5 so this looks like
kind of a sort of French defense with
the bishop down there on C8 what do you
make of this position where black just
stole upon the center and Magnus once
again he's surprised and can't believe
that he's blundering
things I like this position before but
now uh y up a p i don't like what he did
though trading voluntarily going Bishop
B5 he loses a lot of time I think he
should have just gone like Bishop D7 but
now his Queen is under attack this rook
and swing all the way over to H4 and
this looks super unpleasant Robert and
H6 he's going Alpha zero style that
Queen has to go to h8 for oh oh my gosh
the king is just getting mated the
Knight D5 Rook Knight E7 this is so
miserable this is tough I mean where do
you even go with the queen if you take
on B2 maybe Rook B4 the queen has to
leave the diagonal and when you do the
there's going to be Queen D4 and white
has to be winning there this looks tough
this looks tough yeah there's going be a
rook take on E8 Knight F6 check
everything is hanging there so he goes
Knight D6 at long last is even material
and White's King is much much
safer and look at this Rook B4 The Rook
is coming up to B6 this SP on B7 is
super weak Magnus can now just take it
he's going to take on B7 take on A6 and
then all of a sudden he will have three
connected passers on the queen side and
look at this Jan just tries to bring his
Rook to the center but but he's down
three pawns on the queen side as you
mentioned Bishop C4 another really
precise move trading off the Bishops
there is no hope here for black yeah now
his king's head is also getting ripped
apart Magnus can just trade here push
the pawn off the board Rook B8 now and
yeah this is going to be another good
win this is easy there's no threats from
black The Rook on f8 can be traded off
the board I don't even know what to
recommend yep resigning that that's the
thing I would recommend here it looks
over
he's listening he's listening he he and
Y pomi if he had any hopes to win this
match in the bullet those hopes are
dashed because Magnus Carlson is just
too darn good yeah Magnus playing the
filor defense here Jan going for a
Italian setup eventually does go D4 and
uh let's see what Magnus is going to do
here maybe Knight E5 Knight B6 but
Magnus playing out of his mind finding
all of these moves super quickly and
it's tough it's tough if you're young
like Magnus is instincts are just on
another level and this type of setup da
was talking about the other day from the
black side it's very difficult to prove
an advantage for white those D6 pawn it
looks like a Target but black has the
perfect cocoon to keep it safe and
sound exactly yeah the pawn of D6
sometimes is a little bit weak but for
the moment that's KN on E5 is blocking
the diagonal of the bishop the problem
for black and be though is that you're a
little bit cramped for space so I guess
Magus is going to go Bishop D7 Rook 8
and Bishop C8 to at least have this Rook
defending the D6 Pawn Yeah black does
have everything together and look at
this queen B4 move the F4 Pawn the E4
Pawn both feel a little bit loose and
speaking of loose G3 that looks Loosey
Goosey in front of the white king and
black decides to strike but maybe Jan
has had this worked
out yeah I think Magnus rushed here a
little bit with the moves D5 and knight4
it feels like this should backfires the
pawn E4 is so weak and Jon should be
able to pick it up sooner or later for
the moment he has to move a queen though
but this Pawn is going to be a goner w
F5 just trying to make it spicy and the
eval Bar says that Yan made a mistake
here the king is just so open on
H1 right now there's Bishop D3 for
Magnus to block the default and attack
to Knight on G6 Magnus had the move
Bishop takes H3 taking the queen when
will still defending the The Rook on e4
and now it looks like Yan has a slight
edge here in the end game nice move
though Rook D6 hitting the bishop and
putting the Rook on defended Square so
DT C3 will be next and if this is better
for white it's going to be very
difficult to prove but the white king is
closer to the middle and black has to
start defending those
pawns H G4 nice move here by yon okay we
see a trade now yon has to step up his
King but I think it's going to be
difficult to do because whenever your
king steps up Magnus will have a lot of
checks also these pawns over here are
quite loose so you're going to have to
be very careful here if you're white
yeah Bishop E7 a nice move giving up C3
for H4 now Bishop D6 check if the King
has to go to H3 it's very far away from
where it needs to be which is D3 to win
that c Pawn so Bishop ooh Bishop
F6 wait a second so offering to sh of
Bishops with yaan instead goes after the
A5 Pawn also looks good what does black
do here if you take an A5 Bish is a
little bit off though but but what ises
black do I don't know this actually
looks quite decent for white you're
stealing a pawn then your B Pawn is free
so he runs with his King a the king is
trapped for white imagine if that black
king gets all the way into the position
he's threatening made now and you have
to go G5 but then black is a Perpetual
check and
check what a funny
Perpetual yeah this is a draw oh is he
going to do the he's going to milk the
clock a little bit and well just for a
second and there we have to draw and
still over 19 minutes remain in the
match Yan Naomi earns his first half
point in bullet and with an eighto lead
for Magnus Yan has to win all the rest
of the games at this
stage yeah it might almost be
mathematically over Magnus has a has a
hefty Hefty lead and not that much time
left so let's see how Yan will try to
fight back but it's looking tough it is
and this position is also looking nice
for white you see black throw pawns
forward with G5 black probably has to
Castle Queen side but the pawn structure
is favorable for white because of those
double
pawns yeah but at least Yan has a
double-edged game he goes F4 trying to
break open King side but Magnus keeps it
close and Strikes in the center with the
move E4 now however you take you're
going to recapture with the Knight and
then you can follow with a D5 push so G4
I like this move by Yan and he's going
after the white king but D takes C6 does
hit B7 we might just see a bunch of
Trades but Benjamin as I look at this
White's Pawn structure is healthier
those double F pawns but maybe black is
in time with the counterplay against the
E4 Pawn yeah and he takes the pawn queen
F7 by Magnus though hitting the pawn on
C7 which will be Checkmate and the pawn
on F6 but yon does have a time to trade
be careful though because now Queen D7
is a deadly deadly threat so let's see
how he will deal with it Rook d8 comes
to mind trying to trade off White's rook
and go for a back ring Checkmate of your
own but maybe there's just a series of
checks after that instead goes for the
E8 Square oh he had Rook G8 and there
would not have been a good way to stop
Checkmate oh my gosh he rushed it it is
bullet chest they're going to make moves
quickly but Rook G8 would have given Jan
a winning
position on the and right now it looks
like Magus is firmly in the driver seat
Rook takes A4 everything is defended
rookie to I mean I guess maybe he's
trying to take on B2 but maybe now
Magnus can go for the tackles with queen
d8 and Rook a f to
follow to turn this around in this
manner I mean Yan he missed his one
chance and suddenly it is Magnus oh who
could have been on the offensive but he
plays a little slowly
there yeah he3 defending the pawn queen
E2 Now by Yan okay so now the queen can
of move Rook F3 still he is defending
every single Pawn on the board he's got
these passers Queen D6 now though okay
H4 by Yan I don't think you want to
trade no you definitely do not it's
going to be a great Rook end game for
white and still looks good for white
watch out for Queen F3 check that's why
he goes back to the eighth Rank and
white is just picking up H4 nice
technique for Magnus yeah he's slowly
but surely maneuvering his pieces he can
actually take the pawn in case of Queen
D6 there's Rook F4 and you now have
three connected passers on the kingside
G3 defense you have to be careful to not
to allow Queen D5 so let's see how he
will deal with this it's the only way
for oh Queen C5 check after a que take
C7 just leads to M so all of this is a
problem oh there goes the rook and
that's another game for
Magnus can't stop won't stop Magnus
Carlson wins again and Yan pomi he
cannot be having a good time at this
stage of the match yeah right now it's a
nine-point lead for Magnus yon going for
a reversed Pier or or modern however you
want to call it Magnus playing with a G6
here V can hope for a small Edge because
the N of C6 is restricted but yeah
Magnus playing great chess right
now when Magnus plays like this it's
both a treat to watch and a nightmare to
face so for Yap pami the match started
pretty well for him he was up a point
very early on but then Magnus started
finding his footing and it was all
downhill for there for yand pomi so as
we get to the final stretch of games 15
minutes left in the match now we just
get to watch without the pressure of the
match score because it is officially in
the books Magnus Carlson is going to
make his way to the
semis exactly yeah now I think the thing
for Yan is that magnus's instincts are
so good and that really shines through
in the bullet portion he was hanging
with Magnus in the blitz however I think
to give himself a chance he needs to at
least be even going into the bullet and
perhaps even have a small lead but the
fact that he already went into the
bullet portion with a four or
three-point deficit it makes it very
yeah I can't even give any advice I
obviously don't know what it takes to
beat Magnus Carlson there's pretty much
just one player I should say two because
Maxim Vash lra who is playing right
after this against nihal sain he has
beaten Magnus Carlson in the SEC format
but hikaro and Magnus they're the only
two winners of the speed Chess
Championship they continue to show their
dominance exactly yeah so here we're see
Mo Knight C3 by Yan we see trade now
he's got the double pawns and C5 by
Magnus Magnus slow to but surely
outplaying him in this end game now
perhaps B6 Knight B7 Knight D6 and uh
yeah like like you said how do you deal
with the Magnus deaths on fire and
that's just playing out of his mind
playing quickly finding every single
move the only player we can ask like
said is hear nakura and look at this
rerouting Knight B7 Knight to D6 or A5
the C4 Pawn is loose and if you defend
that with a knight to E3 the bishop go
to H6 to remove the guard and pin that
Knight the bishop on C1 has not a single
inch in this position no light of day
for it it's a miserable defense for
white right so maybe you have to sit
with a knight on A3 but if you sit with
a 9 at A3 it's going to be super passive
and black can prepare a central push
with F5 and Y going down to 8 seconds I
think he's he's given up well he knows
that it's mathematically impossible for
him to win this match maybe he does want
to steal a couple games against Magnus
down the stretch but maglas it feels
like he doesn't care what the match
score is he wants to win each and every
game and by the way Jan is playing
pretty well to complicate matters here
yeah Bish four okay now Magnus can
perhaps trade go king of six or he goes
king of six right away but yeah that's
what makes these top players so good
Robert they're super competitive they
they just won every single game they
cannot accept a single loss and that's
why you know we see Magnus andoru year
after year in these
finals and Magnus Scoops up the C3 pun
as you said he wants to win even this
game and goes after the now the A3
Knight and the C4 Pawn next and suddenly
black seems to have a humongous
Advantage yeah black now has three Queen
side passers maybe just B5 or Bishop D4
and now just push the pawns down the
board this has to be a win for black
Robert for sure too many extra pawns
they're easy to push white has an H Bond
but it's on its starting Square this is
no hope for white in this position and
now the a pawn can push for black as
well all three of them oh that's a free
night that's a free oh
he didn't take
it he's like I don't want your knight I
want my three connected on the queen
side yeah that should be good
enough this has to be one for
Magnus the King goes back and now the F
Pawn's about to Queen and Knight G3 wins
there goes the bishop
yeah yeah so black piece I was going to
say benjam I don't even know what more
there is to say Magnus is just crushing
it
right and now he's up 10 points it's
starting to look tough for Jan it's
starting to look tough for Jan I think
right now his only goal would be not to
lose by a 10-point
margin and it's going to be difficult to
do that because there's still 12 minutes
left in this match which means we're
going to get a number of bullet games
and it's very clear that Magnus Carlson
is far stronger in the quickest of time
controls against yanami but Yan he
deserves credit because he kept this
very competitive in the Blitz and then
Magnus was able to run away with it down
the stretch here and
bullet exactly yeah Magnus playing I
would say Magnus is playing at his level
or maybe even a little bit beyond it Jan
however we talked about this before the
match if he wants to give himself a
chance he cannot lose games
unnecessarily but he did have a few
blonders here and there and yeah as we
see then you're just going to have a
tough day at the office against
Magnus every day is probably a tough day
against Magnus Carlson and in this
position Magnus is stealing the queen
side he took B7 A6 is going to be loose
with that Knight on C7 oh his
Queen oh my goodness Magnus just forgot
a knight could capture his
queen and a Bas gamut in the speed chest
Championship who would have fought
Robert not Magnus Carlson but he has a
bad history of the A6 and C7 squares
because a year ago when he was playing
hiar Nakamura I said oh what about
Bishop C7 didn't realize that the Knight
on A6 could capture that Bishop Magnus
played the move and AAR stole that piece
and this was C7 to A6 so there's
something about those two squares that
are difficult for Magnus with those
enemy
Knights yeah I saw someone make a tweet
that Magnus the only thing he sometimes
blunders are Night Moves Like if you
look at some of his losses he he
blunders a night move like a knight fork
or or something of that nature which is
quite interesting and here we see yet
again and he's fortunate that all of his
slips throughout the day losing on time
in a drawn position Mouse slip to lose
not just one but two pawns earlier in
the match and then there to just hang
your queen in a winning position he's so
strong that even after that he's still
up nine
points yeah now he's still dominating
this match he's even better in this game
the rook and C1 is more active than the
rook and B2 and the spa on C4 is a
little bit weak we see Bishop B5 by y
trying to trade with that active Bishop
on
B4 and this end game is one where black
is in the driver seat because that A2
Pawn will be grabbed the Knight on A5 is
in an awkward spot but I guess there's
not too much life to this because the A7
Pawn the C4 Pawn there's a likelihood
that they'll be traded for each other at
some
moment exactly now wait you can take an
A7 because knight4 there's Knight C4
with check so wait Magnus all of a
sudden in trouble C5 by the way is a
game-winning side or KN B7 so Magnus
blundering a second game in a row and he
plays Rook a for to protect his Rook the
Knight does cover that there's no
discover check that will win
material right so let's see how Yan is
going to try to win this one it's still
looking very unpleasant for Magnus he's
down a pawn he's in this pin or
Discovery but Rook A6 now you just go
King here or here well King C5 he wanted
Knight B7 check so there was some tricks
going after the F7 pawn and will we just
see a repetition I don't think Yan wants
that oh but King C8 Magnus maybe
striving for
more right or he thinks that this is the
better move like now he might not be
worse anymore Knight C4 is a threat C5
Knight C4 attacking the Knight you
knight6 but you can just trade the
Knight is almost trapped and then
takeing E3 or or King
C6 and then we just see fullon
liquidation it's a king and pawn endgame
this is obviously a draw the players
know it but Magnus is just going to make
a bunch of moves to burn some of the
match
clock well there are still chances for
Magnus because after this trade if you
get the king to B3 it's winning but can
he can can uh can he make Yan run out of
moves on the queen side for on the king
side first well no because M Jan played
G4 to freeze Black's pawns they just
repeat moves the king's in opposition
and a draw is reached so it's still a
nine-point lead for Magnus Carlson he's
crushing it right now but what is
this I think this is known to be a loss
variation but nobody knows like how to
actually refute this you take on G2 you
you U white has to give up their Rook
gets a strong attack in return but you
have to know what you're doing here with
white and the Knight is coming to F4 and
G6 that's clear the plan but can't black
play Rook takes H7 and then run the king
to G yeah and look at Magnus he is not
liking the way he's playing because he
just saw Rook takes
H7 exactly and we see here the evil bar
is in the middle so it feels like Magnus
did not play in their precise way and
now it's all the way down so actually
this has worked out brilliantly for Yan
Pachi he played a dubious opening but a
very provocative one he made Magnus
prove it Magnus didn't know how to
punish black and now after Queen takes
H7 I think black's just winning it she
liquidate into an end game that's a
beautiful tactic in Black's favor and
Yan pom she finds it and look at Magnet
he kind of gives that face of yeah good
find double exclamation point and he
resigns on the spot so Magnus I don't
think he's enjoying these last couple
games yeah now I think he for sure would
have lost to win by a 10-point margin
but now Yan's closing it down a little
bit he plays the Eline with Knight to G8
Robert what do you make of this opening
he loves doing stuff like that Magnus
has done this in olympiads he's done in
plenty of classical games uh what's it
called the Norwegian lion or rat or I
forget what the name of the opening is
where he puts his Knight on H5 like the
North Sea variation something to that
effect exactly yeah so we see Bishop B7
it looks pretty all right here for black
white is the bishop air but the N C3 is
slightly placed in on the other hand
black is pretty nice development and the
Bishops for the moment aren't that
effective and I love this maneuver here
by Magnus KN of f E6 I wish I could put
my knight to F6 and back to G8 on my
first two moves and get a position like
this I don't know how he does it but we
just saw a bad opening pay off for Jan
and now for Magnus it's the reverse
where his bad opening or not bad but
questionable it looks pretty good for
black at the stage exactly this KN is
jumping around now it has to go back to
H2 and all of wait knightes C5 there a
pawn with Knight F5 check is probably
what he's looking for and there might is
there King F6 there no
way oh he goes for it he he he wins King
of the Hill he wins King of the
Hill you can end the game yeah that's
done King of the Hill we got this but
the King on E5 is somehow safe enough
because Queen C3 check there's D4 and
the King will Scurry back to F6 and the
F5 Knight actually is hanging after
Queen C3 so what a decision from Magnus
getting away with it yeah King F6 and
now he's completely safe Knight D4 do
not take us after queenes D4 your king
is in a deadly check but maybe Rook E8
defend the Knight and if he gets the
king to G7 it's just over at Robert and
if he trades on E6 and brings the king
to E7 that also looks very good so Queen
C3 I really like that move because you
take on D4 Queen takes D4 check your
King has to go to G5 and there might
just be Queen D2 Queen D4 some kind of
draw by
repetition right so let's see what
Magnus is going to do this looks like a
nice little move by Yan I don't see how
this king is getting out of
here I don't either I think I would just
swap Knights on D4 and try to make that
draw if it is indeed a
drop right oh Queen B Robert Knight
takes C6 D4 Knight takes Rook takes E1
and then you take the Knight what a find
that is a beautiful variation that the
Knight on E6 it's free for white to take
oh he takes with the Rook but there's no
way E5 it's over there's no followup and
Magnus wins a brilliant game
Queen B6 there are you kidding me I'm
looking for a draw he finds a way to get
a victory there Magnus Carlson I know it
hasn't been his absolute best because of
some of the mistakes he's made but he's
played a really great day of
Chess that was a brilliant game and yeah
to be fair he should have already won
after King takes E5 but the engineers
finally got the win through a couple
couple moves later but yeah brilliant
stuff there by Magnus and I think
they're looking at the overall match
clock I'm not sure if Yan really even
wants to continue at this point but it
is a match victory for Magnus Carlson
he's going to move on to face Wesley so
in the speeds Championship semi-finals
and Magnus wasn't perfect right we know
that there was some some sloppiness
there a loss on time but it see the
players they're communicating and maybe
the match is over
with right do you think yon has resigned
the match maybe the game was a little
bit too too much and I think you oh wait
they're off yeah I the thing is they are
allowed to uh resign the match if if
they want to but there I think is a
prize money cut that you uh sacrifice
because well the fans they want to see
all the games played and you know it's
good just to play at the last couple
bullet games so we see here that these H
pawns are off the board this is the type
of opening you really only see in the
quickest of time controls but it's fun
for the
fans exactly I he Knight B6 a tricky
little move by y now Knight takes C4
white there it goes upon and Bishop
takes C3 Magnus does not care he just
sacks the rook and Yan doesn't care
about the Rook either well he wants to
keep his King safe because in bullet
chess King safety is Paramount and
suddenly Magnus who dropped a Pawn on C3
is throwing his other pawns up the board
I think both players they really do want
this match to be done let's be honest
about it but for Jan taking a few more
points he won't regret
that no for sure because just to remind
everybody the priz money is split also
proportionally based on the score so
these last couple games still matter a
little bit for couple hundred bucks as
we see here Y is a pretty fine position
with the Rooks on the B and C F fall
putting maximum pressure on the pawn on
C4 yeah it's a position where equal
material but the position is definitely
not even as the C4 Pawn is loose the
dark squares around the white king are
problematic Al and the light squares too
so Knight G4 played taking control of
the light squares permanently as only
black has a light squore
Bishop yeah black is nice position here
to PA on C4 is a little bit weak Knight
E4 by Magnus perhaps he wants go to G3
to put pressure on the bishop and
prepare some H5 push so let's see what
J's going to do maybe like Queen A4 to
hit this Pawn now you can also defend
with Knight E2 but it's of course a
little bit passive it's passive but it
does get the job done and at some point
white would love to double on the E file
but black forces the trade of Rooks the
E7 Pawn while it's targeted it's hard to
bring a second piece into the attack but
your H5 Knight G3 idea you need to keep
an eye on that if you're Yap pishi
right and the Knight can also go to E3
putting pressure on the bishop and
defending the KN the pawn on C4 so I
love this maneuver here by
Magnus looks o what is oh if Bishop
takes there was rookie a check and check
made on h8 Magnus is going for the
kill right now Knight F5 or Knight H5
looks
crushing oh Knight H F5 was better
because of the Rook e eight
stuff wa check you have to go King E7
but that looks deadly you can go to E8
because Rook C6 so where is the knock at
Queen at oh and if King E8 is there
Knight G7 check Rook takes E6 is coming
but what is the threat exactly Robert
can you cannot take because of Rook A1
what do the move here for White Knight G
what a move now he's stting Knight
C6 that is so sweet Knight G7 it's
so Queen G7 oh this also this also
should do the trick he does deliver mate
but rookie 8 kn6 would have been a for
mate that would have been just too much
to
handle right and now Yan opens up with
the move 1 B3 this is officially the
last game of the match to move G4 I've
seen da play this a couple of times
usually goes like H4 or like C4 and
Knight C3 but here we see Magnus taking
advantage of the open H home and Yana
Poma B3 Cowboy he goes for it and we
have a trade of light squore Bishops I
don't think black could possibly be
worse here healthier Pawn structure King
is now well had to move but it's safe
there goes the pawn though yeah I spoke
too soon this is bullet chess after
all exactly Yan up a pawn here with
Magnus having pretty good pce play The
Rook is pretty active the knights are
nicely positioned and but yeah we see
Yan up upon upon here and he can now go
E4 yes because after Knight H4 this Rook
G3 ideas he brings his second Knight
into the game and black targets the D4
Pawn watch out because the King on C1 is
not the safest King as that pawn would
need to be back on B2 to up the dark
squares right so maybe now move like C5
if you take the queen can slide in with
Queen A1 check so I think yon should
have played King B1 to make sure that
none of that ever happens he simply
allows the check the King goes up to D2
and he says no more checks for you but
Queen takes A2 there still looks like
the white king would have been in
danger and this is so impressive Robert
Magnus is down upon but he offers a
trade of Queens he realizes that his
Rooks are so active on the HF there's
nothing for why to do here he cannot set
his Queen side majority in motion and
black is slowly but surely gonna push up
on the king side and how does he do this
he's down a pawn but he's the one trying
to play for more he's got an active King
if you ever push your queenside pawns as
white I think that the king needs to
stay put on D2 otherwise the black king
goes to E3 and that's a problem so wow I
just can't believe what I'm seeing half
the time when Magnus plays end
games yeah oh and Rook H7 he's
sacrificing the G Pawn with want to go
Rook C7 and go after the see to this is
a master class
Robert just the technique it's
unbelievable he knows when to defend
upon Pawn or to go on the offensive and
we've already seen him win nice end
games two Rook end games he's just
winning a pawn now Rook C5 there's no
way to defend the pawn on B5 maybe you
have to go like B6 or maybe some okay go
C4 he's allowing aasan though uh this
looks lost you just trade everything
you're equal on the king side and you're
up a PA the queen side this is over
and just go after this A6 Pawn as long
as you don't allow the white king to F2
and like a e3 Checkmate that would be
the only thing to look out for but it's
not going to
happen right rookie two now King E3 and
I think E4 just wins the wins the game
Rook D2 and then Rook takes D2 and it's
two extra pawns clean conversion for
Magnus Carlson the match is officially
over and Magnus just an unbelievable
skill set in the end game to take down
yand pomi in another
one exactly he beats y by an 11-point
margin and scores 20 a half points a
very impressive display here in bullet
portion and it's the first time in all
nine of his SEC matches that yand pomi
has not reached double digits so he
didn't get to 10 cuz Magnus Carlson was
not in a giving move past the point of a
few sloppy in instances but Magnus even
after all that he wins 20 half to 9 and
half Benjamin it's
ridiculous that was an extremely
dominant performance look at the
scorecard here Robert he took a
two-point lead going out of the five
plus one portion then he won the three
plus one portion by three points and
finally he dominated in a bullet he's
just too good when Magnus is UN formed
like this even the best players in the
world they struggle to put up a fight so
Magnus Carlson many great moments from
him I'm sure he's was shaking his head
because he believes he can always play
better that's the striving for
Perfection that these top players must
have in order to push themselves to even
higher Heights but Benjamin many many
Great Moments and I uh think that Magnus
has a lot to be proud of yeah for sure
he played some great chess uh today
where he's going to join soon for an
interview but yeah overall he's he's
played some some great chess and he
played some Savvy moves so we are
delighted to take a look at the Savvy
moves presented by coinbase we will be
reviewing a key move from magnus's games
against Yan and Benjamin you know there
were so many to choose from but I
thought that that Rook takes E3 Pawn to
F4 idea by him that was the icing on the
cake right so
um wait sorry which game was that again
it was that bullet game I don't even
remember what number at this point but
it was the game 20 of the match
overall all right let me uh look
wait don't worry everybody we we'll get
it we're going to get it we have to go
back into the archives to find it and
that's just how many games they play in
the speed just championship format but
that move Rook takes E3 I think uh we
have it just about ready now to show
everybody The Savvy move of the day and
Benjamin take us
away exactly so here after night to H3
Magnus was already in a dominant
position with all of his pieces active
but here he found the move Rook takes e
E3 sacrificing The Exchange after Magnus
after yon took he's not interested in
recapturing instead he goes for the move
F4 attacking the Knight on H3 and The
Rook on E3 and all of a sudden there's
nothing white can do white is completely
lost if you take an F4 black cre
captures with a knight not only is black
of material but they're also threatening
a deadly attack on G2 and KN H3 is also
a threat so Yan played the move Rook
Rook E4 but now Magnus takes the Knight
Knight F1 and now Knight E3 and after
takes he takes the rook and Magnus won a
crushing game with the black pieces and
that was your Savvy move of the day
presented by coin base and it extended
magnus's lead in the match of seven
points and there was no looking back
from there so Magnus Carlson with some
sexy tactics if we could say so
ourselves and we are going to have
Magnus Carlson joining us for an
interview so chat please ask questions
some of them may be featured and asked
to none other than the top player in the
world Magnus Carlson so we are going to
head to a break but when we return it's
an interview with Magnus himself here at
the speeches Championship presented by
[Music]
coinbase
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved chess.com
game review is just a click away game
review is a fast fun and instructive
guided review of your games see your
accuracy and your opponent's accuracy
check out the eval graph for an instant
overview and scroll down to see how many
great moves best moves blunders and yes
brilliancies you have played learn from
chess.com coach who gives move
explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play with
retry mistakes you can get another shot
at finding missed opportunities try game
review today on web iOS or Android
September Bots are here and it's time
for a Monumental Clash this Barbarian
might not Crush you on the board but he
certainly can Crush you with The Bard
speaking of crushing this giant is a
living Siege Tower usually found in
groups goblins are fond of sharp pointy
objects and other people's
pieces the battle hardened Valkyrie
might give you a game once she's done
arm wrestling a
Golem this hog rider and his Noble Steed
might give you a headache or two
skeletons adore her B fear her you'll
need to bring your aame if you want want
to beat this witch yes that probably is
a rabbit up his sleeve or a huge
Fireball with your name on it we hear
Wizards are pretty good at chess not
just a killing machine Pekka loves tiny
butterflies but you'll probably not a
butterfly so watch out the Archer Queen
thinks highly of herself and for good
reason she is a skilled tactician deadly
opponent and your worst nightmare play
them all on chest
[Music]
com
[Applause]
n
[Music]
[Applause]
he
[Music]
and welcome back everyone to the speed
chest Championship presented by coinbase
unfortunately we lost Robert due to some
technical issues but we are joined by a
very special guest Magnus you just beat
Jan in a very convincing manner how do
you feel about
match um it was um yeah it was a slug
really
from from the first moment
um I didn't actually know that I was
going to play today uh I was until I in
the middle I was in the middle of a 21
course meal yesterday and
then um like in the evening and then I
found out out that I'm going to play the
match and to be honest I was still so so
feeling so sluggish
so um yeah um I think like against vit I
played okay probably today I played
quite a bit worse um it's not only about
the moves um I did miss a lot of tactics
but um you wouldn't believe the things
that I actually missed that didn't show
up on the board so um yeah it was
um I think not a great day of uh of
Chess um felt
like um Yan really never got going after
he lost that fourth game which was
pretty unnecessary and um um yeah then
it was kind of close but I
never uh never felt that I was
particularly in danger um but it never
never felt like I was playing well
either so it was
just race to the finish line and yeah
eventually we got
there yeah that fourth game felt
critical indeed that Jan also could have
won but overall you you did impress us
with your chess and Magnus how do you
feel about facing Wesley so in the
semi-finals um yeah of course
uh uh he
had yeah one of the most exciting
matches of um of all time against Alesa
I was uh following most of that
um
he's
generally um you know very strong but
also he's a bit like Yan that he he play
plays well and then he's really tilty
some sometimes so that's I think what he
needs
to to sort of avoid to make
the the the match match close um and for
me I just have to you know prepare
better to be better physically um
because yeah now like I'm relatively
rested but like my brain is my brain is
fried so if I'm in in good shape then
he's going to have to play at his very
best to
to make it uh
exciting yeah know we definitely look
forward to that match and uh yeah it
would be awesome if you can play even
better there and uh Magnus who do you fa
who do you wish to face in the finals if
you
qualify um to paraphrase what uh grishuk
said in an interview a few years ago um
it doesn't matter uh whom I wish to play
because it's most probably going to be
hiara so um for me it's all about yeah
performing a bit better in the next
match and then I'm assuming that he'll
be there if I get
that yeah and it would be awesome to see
a rematch again all right Magnus we're
gonna let you go we're going to let you
uh rest enjoy your rest of your evening
cuz we have to get ready for our next
match but we thank you for
joining yeah thank you that's going to
be um awesome very evenly matched I
think all right so yeah it was an honor
to have Magnus here on the show so let's
have a quick look at our bracket we see
now that one semi-final is set up
between Magnus Carlson and Wesley s so
the big question is who is going to face
hikara Nakamura in the other semi-final
is it going to be nihal serin or Max see
Vash lra we are going to find out very
soon as that one is coming up in just a
bit all right so we are gonna go on a
break don't go anywhere any anywhere
guys because this the other semi-final
is coming up very soon between Nial sain
and Maxim VRA I'm going to be joined by
my good friend Diana nitki so we will
see you in just uh in just a
few
[Music]
n
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
a
[Music]